This episode is brought to you by the Lloyd's 5K House Deposit, and this is something that was last seen in 1996. Yeah, so the 1990s looks now like a lost golden age of prosperity and positivity, doesn't it? Think of the sort of the advent of the Blair administration in 1997, all the enthusiasm and excitement that surrounded that, the economic growth at the time, the technological developments, the sort of sense of an endless golden summer where everybody is listening to Blair and Oasis and looking forward to to buying their first houses, and that of course takes us to mortgages. Now, the good news is that in a nod to the 1990s, Lloyds are offering 5K deposit mortgages to first-time buyers. So search 5K first-time buyer. Ninety-six, average first-time buyer deposits are based on ONS data. Subject to status, your home may be repossessed if you don't keep up repayments and conditions
本期节目由劳埃德银行5000英镑房屋首付贷款赞助播出，这项优惠上一次出现还是在1996年。没错，现在的20世纪90年代看起来就像是一个失落的繁荣与积极的黄金时代，不是吗？想想1997年布莱尔政府上台时的那种盛况，周围洋溢的热情与兴奋，当时的经济增长，技术的发展，那种仿佛无尽的金色夏天，每个人都在听着布莱尔和绿洲乐队的歌，期待着购买他们的第一套房子，而这自然就让我们想到了抵押贷款。现在，好消息是，为了向90年代致敬，劳埃德银行为首次购房者提供了5000英镑首付的抵押贷款。所以请搜索“5K首次购房者”。96年，首次购房者的平均首付数据基于英国国家统计局。受条件限制，如果您未能按时还款，您的房屋可能会被收回，且适用相关条款。
apply. An old servant was waiting for us by a small iron door. He led us through a number of dark stairs and rooms until he asked us to enter a certain door as I crossed the threshold. A black bird, some kind of raven, flew at my head. A voice called from the next room. Please come in.
一位老仆人在一扇小铁门旁等着我们。他带着我们穿过几段昏暗的楼梯和房间，直到他让我们进入某扇门，当我跨过门槛时，一只黑色的鸟，某种乌鸦，向我的头扑来。隔壁房间传来一个声音：“请进。”
Marie, I should. me in. We talked a while about Vienna. Then he said to me, Pardon me, but I would like to talk to the countess privately for a few minutes. And then he went with Marie to another room. I looked around me. On his desk was a revolver and a skull. It picked up the skull, took it between my hands, and looked at it From all sides, suddenly Rodolf came in and took it from me with deep apprehension. But when I said that I wasn't afraid, he smiled. So that is an amazing scene like something, and we said it before, from a kind of gothic
“玛丽，我应该……进来。”我们聊了一会儿维也纳。然后他对我说：“请原谅，我想和伯爵夫人私下谈几分钟。”接着他和玛丽去了另一个房间。我环顾四周。他的书桌上放着一把左轮手枪和一个骷髅头。我拿起骷髅头，把它捧在手里，从各个角度观察它。突然，鲁道夫走了进来，带着深深的忧虑从我手中拿走了它。但当我告诉他我不害怕时，他笑了。所以，这是一个令人惊叹的场景，就像我们之前说过的，来自某种哥特式
melodrama, Egerlin Poe or something like that. But in fact, that is a letter that was written by the 17-year-old Baroness Mary Vetsera to her old governess in the autumn of 1888. In fact, it's like something out of Dracula, isn't it? A letter written to a governess by a 17-year-old girl who has invited herself into the room of an exceedingly sinister man. And she is describing there a secret meeting with the heir to the throne of the Austro-Hungarian Empire, Crown Prince Rudolph. And this has happened a few days earlier on the 5th of November. And Dominic, if listeners, which I hope they will have done, have heard our first episode, then they will know where this is
情节剧，爱伦·坡之类的作品。但事实上，这是一封17岁的玛丽·维采拉女男爵在1888年秋天写给她前任家庭教师的信。事实上，这就像《德古拉》里的情节，不是吗？一个17岁的女孩写给家庭教师的信，她不请自来地进入了一个极其阴险的男人的房间。她在信中描述了与奥匈帝国皇位继承人——鲁道夫皇储的一次秘密会面。这发生在几天前的11月5日。多米尼克，如果听众们——我希望他们已经听过了——听过我们的第一集，那么他们就会知道这
heading. And it is nowhere good for Baroness Mary, because she is heading to a hunting lodge at Marling in the Vienna woods. And what happens there is going to be one of the greatest scandals in the entire history, not just of Austro-Hungarian, but of European royalty, it is going to be a murder-suicide pact that will shake the Habsburg dynasty to its very foundations. So Dominic, it's an amazing story. Yeah, it is an amazing, amazing tale. And today we'll be telling the story of that secret affair between Rudolph and Mary. We will get deep into what exactly happened and myeling, and we'll talk about the implications
指向哪里。这对玛丽女男爵来说绝非好事，因为她正前往维也纳森林中迈耶林的狩猎小屋。在那里发生的事情将成为整个历史上，不仅是奥匈帝国，也是欧洲皇室历史上最大的丑闻之一，这将是一场动摇哈布斯堡王朝根基的谋杀与自杀协议。所以，多米尼克，这是一个令人惊叹的故事。是的，这是一个令人惊叹、令人惊叹的故事。今天我们将讲述鲁道夫和玛丽之间那段秘密恋情的故事。我们将深入探讨迈耶林到底发生了什么，并讨论其对
for the Habsburg dynasty and for the Austro-Hungarian Empire. But just to remind ourselves exactly when and where we are. We're in Vienna in 1888, the world of Klimt and Freud and Marla and these titanic cultural figures. Also the world of Crown Prince Rudolph, the sinister man and the Gothic melodrama that you described so chillingly, I have to say, in your introductory reading. Thank you. So Crown Prince Rudolf is 30 years old. He is, to remind people, he is the son of Emperor Franz Joseph and his very glamorous kind of melancholy wife, Cici. Very thin, very long hair.
哈布斯堡王朝和奥匈帝国的影响。但先提醒一下我们所处的具体时间和地点。我们身处1888年的维也纳，那是克里姆特、弗洛伊德、马勒这些泰斗级文化人物的世界。这也是鲁道夫皇储的世界，那个阴险的男人，以及你在开场白中描述得如此令人不寒而栗的哥特式情节剧。谢谢。那么，鲁道夫皇储今年30岁。提醒一下大家，他是弗朗茨·约瑟夫皇帝和他那位迷人但忧郁的妻子茜茜公主的儿子。非常瘦，留着长发。
And Rudolph, who takes after his mother, I think it's reasonable to surmise. He is a very troubled, unhappy, kind of morbid young man. He's almost certainly suffering from incurable gonorrhea. He's probably off his face on morphine. And he is suffocated by the kind of expectations of his role, crown prince. And also, I think he is being eaten away by a sense of uselessness and futility as he waits for his father to die and to vacate the throne. And into Rudolph's orbit, as we described last time, has come the teenage Baroness Mary Betzara. She is precocious.
而鲁道夫，我认为可以合理推测，他长得像他的母亲。他是一个非常困扰、不快乐、有点病态的年轻人。他几乎可以肯定患有无法治愈的淋病。他可能沉迷于吗啡。他被皇储这一角色的期望所窒息。而且，我认为他在等待父亲去世并让出皇位时，正被一种无用感和徒劳感所吞噬。正如我们上次所描述的，十几岁的玛丽·维采拉女男爵进入了鲁道夫的轨道。她早熟，
She's a social butterfly. She's a social climber. She's ambitious, but she's also incredibly romantic in a very 17-year-old sort of teenage girl way. Well, you could see, couldn't you, from that extract that she wrote? Is it actually like a Gothic melodrama or is she putting that spin on it? Of course. A bit of both, probably. Was there really a blackbird, you know? Yeah, I mean, it's improbable.
她是一个社交名媛。她是一个攀附权贵的人。她很有野心，但同时又以一种17岁少女特有的方式极其浪漫。嗯，你可以从她写的那段摘录中看出来，不是吗？这真的是哥特式情节剧吗，还是她自己在添油加醋？当然。可能两者都有。真的有乌鸦吗，你知道的？是的，我的意思是，这不太可能。
And she had gone to that meeting with her older friend, Countess Marie Larish, who is Rudolph's cousin. And basically the Countess, Larish, has acted as the sort of intermediary and put the two of them together. The board. She is the board. Yeah. You could say she is the...
她和她的年长朋友玛丽·拉里什伯爵夫人一起去参加了那次会面，拉里什伯爵夫人是鲁道夫的表亲。基本上，拉里什伯爵夫人充当了中间人的角色，把他们撮合在了一起。她是那个中间人。她是那个中间人。是的。你可以说她是……
procurer, as it were. So the events that you described, Monday the 5th of November 1888, we ended the last episode with this scene. Countess Larrish has offered to take Mary's shopping with their mother's permission. They went to the Graben, the Great Shopping Street in Vienna. They went to a society photographer to have Mary's picture taken, but then they went to the back entrance to the Grand Hotel, to a carriage, which was waiting for them, driven by Rudolph's coachman, Yosef Bratfish.
拉皮条的，可以这么说。所以你描述的那些事件，1888年11月5日星期一，我们上一集结束时就是这个场景。拉里什伯爵夫人提出在得到玛丽母亲许可的情况下带玛丽去购物。他们去了维也纳的大购物街格拉本大街。他们去了一位社交摄影师那里给玛丽拍照，但随后他们去了大酒店的后门，那里有一辆马车在等着他们，由鲁道夫的车夫约瑟夫·布拉特菲什驾驶。
Bradfish. Yeah. It's a great name. That is worthy of an American. Totally. It is. Yeah. And Dominic, this whole thing about women being taken to the, you know, to hotels,
布拉特菲什。是的。这名字真棒。这值得一个美国人拥有。完全是。是的。多米尼克，关于女性被带到，你知道的，酒店，
the back rooms of hotels and things and being driven off in carriages, faint echo of Diana about this, isn't there? We've kind of mentioned it in the context of Cici. Yeah, definitely there is. I mean, it's very much a kind of Diana in the 1990s vibe to this, I think. Yeah. The Diana's story doesn't quite have that Gothic element. to it there, does it? It's rather more Hello magazine. This is much more Hello magazine meets
酒店的后室之类的地方，然后被马车载走，这有点戴安娜王妃事件的影子，不是吗？我们在提到茜茜公主时也提到过这一点。是的，绝对有。我的意思是，这非常有90年代戴安娜的那种氛围，我想。是的。戴安娜的故事并没有那种哥特式元素，对吧？它更像是《Hello》杂志。这更像是《Hello》杂志遇见了
Bram Stoker, as you said. Yeah. So from there, she was taken to the Hofberg, the Imperial Palace, to Rudolph's private apartments, and then we get the scene with the Raven and the skull. And so begins their relationship, their affair. Now, this is not unusual for Rudolph. Rudolph has had a lot of affairs, and all the time, he's still seeing his chief, his regular mistress, who is the former courtizan Mitzi Kaspar. And Mary herself, actually, this is not her first rodeo. So she, for an aristocratic girl of 17, is probably quite experienced. She'd been on a trip to Egypt a year earlier.
布莱姆·斯托克，正如你所说。是的。从那里，她被带到了霍夫堡皇宫，带到了鲁道夫的私人公寓，然后我们就看到了乌鸦和骷髅头的场景。于是他们的关系，他们的恋情开始了。现在，这对鲁道夫来说并不罕见。鲁道夫有过很多风流韵事，而且一直以来，他还在见他的首席情妇，也就是前交际花米齐·卡斯帕。而玛丽本人，实际上，这也不是她的第一次了。所以，对于一个17岁的贵族女孩来说，她可能相当有经验。一年前她曾去过埃及。
And it was generally thought that she'd been carrying on with a British brigadier. Oh, my goodness. Not General Gordon. Yeah. That would be improbable. Wow, that's a twist. General Gordon, who is still alive in this version of history. Okay, fine.
人们普遍认为她曾与一位英国准将有过一段情。哦，天哪。不是戈登将军吧。是的。那太不可思议了。哇，这真是个转折。戈登将军，在这个版本的历史中他还活着。好吧，没关系。
Well, anyway, she's had loads of admirers, not just Crown Prince Rudolph. So what makes this particular liaison so special? Well, you described how Mary Vetsera's account owes something to Gothic melodrama. But it pales by comparison with this, which is from Rudolph's military aide Victor von Fristier. And he tells this absolutely extraordinary story. He said later, you know, when we were young men, we were stationed in Prague when we were younger. And we went, me and Karen Prince Rudolf, to the ghetto cemetery.
总之，她有很多仰慕者，不仅仅是鲁道夫皇储。那么是什么让这段恋情如此特别呢？嗯，你描述了玛丽·维采拉的叙述如何带有哥特式情节剧的色彩。但与这个相比就显得苍白无力了，这是来自鲁道夫的军事副官维克多·冯·弗里斯特的描述。他讲述了这个绝对非凡的故事。他后来在说，你知道，当我们年轻时，我们在布拉格驻扎。我和鲁道夫皇储去了犹太区墓地。
You know the old town cemetery in Prague? Very evocative, moving. With the grave of the rabbi who created the golem. The golem, exactly. The kind of prototype for Frankenstein. So this really kind of haunting, spooky kind of landscape. And they went there and the cantor was singing prayers during a funeral. and Rudolph was very taken by this according to his aid
你知道布拉格的老城公墓吗？非常令人回味，感人。那里有创造了“魔像”的拉比的坟墓。魔像，没错。弗兰肯斯坦的原型。所以这是一种非常令人难忘、阴森的景观。他们去了那里，领唱在葬礼上唱着祈祷文。据他的副官说，鲁道夫被深深打动了，
and particularly by the Cantor's raven-haired daughter and she became obsessed with Crown Prince Rudolph too so obsessed that her father had to send her to a provincial town to get her away from him but she came back to Prague she stood every night under his castle window through the winter Rudolph eventually found out that she was standing underneath his window but when he sent people to look for her they reported that she had just caught pneumonia and died. And Rudolph went secretly to her grave and left roses by her tombstone.
特别是被领唱那头乌黑头发的女儿所吸引，她也对鲁道夫皇储着了迷，着迷到她父亲不得不把她送到一个偏远小镇以让她远离他。但她回到了布拉格，整个冬天她每天晚上都站在他的城堡窗下。鲁道夫最终发现她站在他的窗下，但当他派人去找她时，他们报告说她刚得了肺炎去世了。鲁道夫秘密地去了她的坟墓，并在她的墓碑旁留下了玫瑰。
So do you think there's a possibility that that raven was the reincarnation of this girl who died of, and I imagine, it wasn't pneumonia, I imagine it was a consumption. Well, I think Victor von Fritch has a very lively imagination. Because Victor von Fritch, Rudolph's aide, said, the Crown Prince clearly believed that this Mary Vatsera was the reincarnation of this Jewish girl from Prague. Oh God, there is a reincarnation. And this is why he was so obsessed with her. This is his interpretation. Whether listeners believe this, I'll leave to them.
那你认为那只乌鸦有可能是这个死于——我想，那不是肺炎，我想是肺结核——的女孩的转世吗？嗯，我认为维克多·冯·弗里奇有非常活跃的想象力。因为鲁道夫的副官维克多·冯·弗里奇说，皇储显然相信这个玛丽·维采拉就是那个布拉格犹太女孩的转世。哦，天哪，竟然有转世。这就是他为什么如此迷恋她的原因。这是他的解释。听众们是否相信这一点，我留给他们自己判断。
I mean, I don't think she probably, I don't think she was the reincarnation of this girl, but who knows? But I suppose the question is whether Rudolph might have thought that. He might have done. He might have done because he has that kind of sensibility, doesn't he? He absolutely does. And the way their relationship has carried out is all like they're sort of cosplaying in a gothic melodrama. So they would always meet kind of a dusk in the shadows or they'd meet in his very gloomy kind of palace apartment with the skull on the table. I mean, they would so be into black eye shadow in that if they live now, wouldn't they?
我的意思是，我不认为她可能是那个女孩的转世，但谁知道呢？但我认为问题在于鲁道夫是否可能这样想。他可能想过。他可能想过，因为他有那种敏感性，不是吗？他绝对有。而且他们维持关系的方式就像是在玩哥特式情节剧的Cosplay。所以他们总是会在黄昏的阴影中见面，或者在那种放着骷髅头的阴暗宫殿公寓里见面。我的意思是，如果他们活在现在，他们绝对会画黑色眼影，不是吗？
They completely would. They're total goths, aren't they? Or emo or whatever. Yeah. So they would be, they're going on these sort of ride, carriage rides in the dusk through the abandoned deserted Prata Park and all of this. After a few days, Rudolph gave her an iron wedding ring. It was inscribed with the letters, I-L-V-B-I-D-T, in Lieberaint-B-E-E-T-T, through love united unto death.
他们绝对会。他们是彻头彻尾的哥特人，不是吗？或者是情绪摇滚之类的。是的。所以他们会，他们会在黄昏时分乘坐马车穿过荒废的普拉特公园，诸如此类。几天后，鲁道夫给了她一枚铁质结婚戒指。上面刻着字母“I-L-V-B-I-D-T”，即“In Liebe vereint bis in den Tod”，意为“因爱结合，直至死亡”。
And she wore it on a kind of chain under her bodice. And she is clearly absolutely infatuated with him in a very recognizable kind of teenage way. So she wrote to her old governess, if I could give my life to make him happy, I would gladly do it because I do not value my own life. And in one of these letters, she says to her governess, we've discussed what would happen if people found out about us. We have made a pact covering such an eventuality.
她把它戴在胸前的一条链子上。她显然以一种非常典型的青少年方式对他极其迷恋。所以她写信给她的前家庭教师说，如果我能献出生命让他快乐，我会很乐意这样做，因为我不珍惜自己的生命。在其中一封信中，她对家庭教师说，我们讨论过如果人们发现我们的关系会发生什么。我们已经针对这种情况制定了一份协议。
After a few happy hours at a place nobody knows, we will enter death forever. Now, at one level, this is not unusual. This is the kind of slightly madly overwrought thing that teenage girls who are going out with married older men, right. He hates his wife. He will abandon me and we will go into the shadows, all of this. Especially in fantasy ecla, Vienna. Exactly. That kind of mood of lush morbidity.
在无人知晓的地方度过几个快乐的时光后，我们将永远步入死亡。现在，从某种层面上讲，这并不罕见。这就是那些和已婚年长男人交往的少女会有的那种稍微有点疯狂、过度激动的想法，对吧。他讨厌他的妻子。他会抛弃我，我们将步入阴影，诸如此类。特别是在充满幻想的维也纳。没错。那种郁郁葱葱的病态情绪。
Yeah, completely. On the other hand, there are hints that Rudolph, you know, sees this as something more than just a sort of love lord joke or something. So on All Souls Day, on the 2nd of November, he met his mother's lady in waiting, Countess Festertich in a palace corridor. And he said, are you off to the cemetery, countess? And she said, yes, your Imperial Highness, to pray for my dead. when I'm gone, will you pray for me? Will you include me among your dead? And she said, your Imperial Highness is smiling.
是的，完全是。另一方面，有迹象表明鲁道夫，你知道，认为这不仅仅是一个恋爱中的玩笑之类的。所以在万灵节，11月2日，他在宫殿走廊里遇到了他母亲的侍女费斯特蒂奇伯爵夫人。他说：“你要去墓地吗，伯爵夫人？”她说：“是的，皇室殿下，去为我的死者祈祷。”“当我不在了，你会为我祈祷吗？你会把我列入你的死者名单吗？”她说：“皇室殿下在笑。”
It is a joke. A smile doesn't always mean a joke. Your Imperial Highness, I'm much older than you. I pray God, I shall never have a chance to do what you ask. I mean, he's clearly a man who's just walking around the palace talking to people unnecessarily about death and about his own death. Yeah. Anyway, the weeks pass.
“这是一个玩笑。”“微笑并不总是意味着玩笑。”“皇室殿下，我比你大得多。我祈求上帝，我永远不会有机会做你要求的事。”我的意思是，他显然是一个在宫殿里走来走去，不必要地与人谈论死亡和他自己死亡的人。是的。总之，几周过去了。
In early December, I mean, don't forget, they haven't been going out very long. They've been going about four weeks. In early December, Countess Lepard. has to go back to her husband's estate in Bohemia, and they need a new way of hooking up Rudolph and Mary. And the way they find is through the unlikely romantic lubricant that is Richard Wagner. He's very romantic. I mean, literally, you know, the song is death. I suppose, yeah, but I mean, if you said to somebody, why don't we use Wagner as an excuse to go on dates, I mean, that's a very particular vibe, is it not? When I entirely approve of all. I mean, the thing is,
12月初，我的意思是，别忘了，他们交往的时间并不长。他们大约交往了四周。12月初，拉里什伯爵夫人不得不回到她在波希米亚的丈夫的庄园，他们需要一种新的方式来撮合鲁道夫和玛丽。他们找到的方法是通过理查德·瓦格纳这种不太可能的浪漫润滑剂。他非常浪漫。我的意思是，字面上看，你知道，歌剧就是死亡。我想，是的，但我的意思是，如果你对某人说，为什么我们不把瓦格纳作为约会的借口，我的意思是，这是一种非常独特的氛围，不是吗？我完全赞同这一切。我的意思是，问题是，
if she doesn't like Wagner, then perhaps she'd be better off going out with the Kaiser. Yes, exactly. Who had laughed and chatted all the way through for Barkner in the previous episode. Yeah. And also, the Kaiser's, not a man who's ever going to top himself, right? The Kaiser is a better investment. I think so. Yes, I think so.
如果她不喜欢瓦格纳，那么也许她最好和凯撒约会。是的，没错。他在上一集中对瓦格纳的音乐全程大笑和聊天。是的。而且，凯撒也不是那种会自杀的人，对吧？凯撒是一个更好的投资。我想是的。是的，我想是的。
He's also not riddle with gonorrhea. Well, quite. So, anyway, the court opera is doing this big new production of the ring cycle, starting with Das Reingold and the Vets eras have a box at the opera but Mary says to her mother oh hey Wagner this would have been a red flag for you Tom
他也没有患上淋病。嗯，确实。所以，总之，宫廷歌剧院正在上演《指环》系列的新制作，从《莱茵的黄金》开始，维采拉一家在歌剧院有包厢，但玛丽对她母亲说：“哦，嘿，瓦格纳……”如果你和玛丽在Hinge上匹配，这本来会是一个危险信号，汤姆。
if you and Mary had matched on hinge you'd have been like what no interest in Wagner unbelievable I'm out so she tells her mother I'm not going to Vargna she keeps coming out of the excuses not to go and then when her mother and sister
如果你和玛丽在Hinge上匹配，你会说：“什么？对瓦格纳没兴趣？难以置信，我退出。”所以她告诉她母亲：“我不去听瓦格纳。”她不断找借口不去，然后当她母亲和姐姐
went off to the opera she would slip out of the house Bratfish the coachman would be waiting at the corner I can't believe he's called Brat fish. And he would drive her to Shunbrun Palace, the Austrian Versailles, and she and Rudolph would kind of walk in the darkness of the park. And then she'd always be back in time for her mother and sister's return at 10 o'clock. So it's brilliant, isn't it? The Barclos operas are so long. Amazing. But there's still no sort of
去听歌剧时，她就会溜出家门。布拉特菲什车夫会在拐角处等着。我不敢相信他叫“布拉特鱼”。他会开车送她去美泉宫，奥地利的凡尔赛宫，她和鲁道夫会在公园的黑暗中散步。然后她总能在她母亲和姐姐10点回来之前赶回去。这太聪明了，不是吗？瓦格纳的歌剧太长了。太棒了。但似乎仍然没有
physical side to this relationship, it seems. Frederick Morton in his book, Inervis Spendor, says the reason is that Rudolph is postponing this because Rudolph believed that climax meant end, meaning death. It's sad, isn't he, that Freud never got the chance to psychoanalyze him. I know. He just feels an ideal patient. Completely with his mother, his distant father, all of this. The yearning for death. I mean, it's, yeah.
身体上的关系。弗雷德里克·莫顿在他的书《内在的辉煌》中说，原因是鲁道夫推迟了这一点，因为鲁道夫认为高潮意味着结束，意味着死亡。他真可怜，不是吗？弗洛伊德从未有机会对他进行心理分析。我知道。他感觉是一个理想的病人。完全是因为他的母亲、疏远的父亲，所有这些。对死亡的渴望。我的意思是，是的。
Anyway, we get to Christmas. So the imperial family for once are actually reunited at the palace. Cece's birthday is on Christmas Eve, it's a Rudolf's mother's birthday. And that in Austria is when the Christkind brings your presence, the Christchild. He's just got back from Corfu, which she loves. You've seen her palace in Corfu, have you not?
总之，到了圣诞节。所以皇室成员难得在宫殿团聚。茜茜公主的生日是平安夜，也就是鲁道夫母亲的生日。在奥地利，那是圣婴带来礼物的时候。她刚从她热爱的科孚岛回来。你见过她在科孚岛的宫殿吗？
Yeah, the Killian. And she's come back from Corfu with an anchor tattooed on her shoulder. Yeah. Which is punchy. I always thought this was unusual behaviour. But a whole host of members of royal families throughout the late 19th century were doing it. Yeah. So it had obviously become a kind of royal craze.
是的，阿喀琉斯宫。她从科孚岛回来时，肩膀上纹了一个锚。是的。这很有冲击力。我一直认为这是不寻常的行为。但19世纪末整个皇室家族的许多成员都在这样做。是的。所以这显然已经成为一种皇室狂热。
It was, exactly. George V and his brother went off to Japan, I think, who got dragons tattooed on their arms or something. Incredible. Anyway, they gathered in Cece's apartment that night, and Rudolf very thoughtfully had laid the table with presents. He got her a book of letters by Heine, who was her favourite German writer, and a packet of 11 original Heiner letters that he had sent to a relative in Paris. That is thoughtful, Dominic, because there's nothing more thoughtful than giving someone a letter written by someone they particularly admire. Can you think of an example of this, Tom? Anyone who does that, I think, is beneath the show of cynical cruelty or whatever it is.
确实，没错。乔治五世和他的兄弟去了日本，我想，他们的手臂上纹了龙之类的东西。不可思议。总之，那天晚上他们聚集在茜茜公主的公寓里，鲁道夫非常体贴地在桌子上摆放了礼物。他送给她一本海涅的信件集，海涅是她最喜欢的德国作家，还有一包他从巴黎寄给亲戚的11封海涅亲笔信。这很体贴，多米尼克，因为没有什么比送给某人他们特别钦佩的人写的信更体贴的了。你能想到一个例子吗，汤姆？任何这样做的人，我认为，都处于愤世嫉俗的残忍或类似行为之下。
Yeah. A cherubic lovable. Is there anything you want to share with the listeners? Yeah, because you bought me a letter written by Nelson. There you go. Thank you. One of my most treasured possessions. That comparison with Crown Prince Rudolph that has dogged me all my life, yet more ammunition to the people who say,
是的。一个可爱的天使。有什么你想和听众分享的吗？是的，因为你给我买了一封纳尔逊写的信。给你。谢谢。我最珍贵的财产之一。那个与鲁道夫皇储的比较一直伴随着我一生，这又为那些说……的人提供了弹药。
Is he the reincarnation of Crown Prince Rudolph? Because the parallels are uncanny. Yeah, they are. I would work on an encyclopedia if my father ordered me to. And he's been working on his Austro-Hungarian encyclopedia. So he's got copies of that wrapped up. I mean, you write history books that are like encyclopedias. Correct.
他是鲁道夫皇储的转世吗？因为相似之处太不可思议了。是的，它们是。如果我父亲命令我，我会去编写百科全书。他一直在编写他的奥匈帝国百科全书。所以他把那些副本包了起来。我的意思是，你写的历史书就像百科全书一样。正确。
Yeah, thank you. I was fishing for that. And there are the presents all around. So Franz Joseph and Cece have got presents for Rudolph and Stefan, his daughter, or Elizabeth. I mean, it's often forgotten in this story that he has a daughter. I think she's about five or six. And they've got her kind of toy garden furniture made in Corfu. Can I just ask?
是的，谢谢。我是在钓鱼。礼物都在周围。所以弗朗茨·约瑟夫和茜茜为鲁道夫和斯蒂芬妮，他的女儿，或者伊丽莎白准备了礼物。我的意思是，在这个故事中经常被遗忘的是他有一个女儿。我想她大约五六岁。他们为她准备了在科孚岛制作的玩具花园家具。我可以问一下吗？
He's got a lovely present for his mother. Yeah. Has he got anything for his father? No mention. No mention of that. It's not his father's birthday, though, to be fair. That's true. Also, what do you give the man who owns Central Europe?
他为他母亲准备了一份可爱的礼物。是的。他为他父亲准备了什么吗？没提。没提。不过公平地说，那不是他父亲的生日。那是真的。还有，你给拥有中欧的男人什么呢？
A uniform? Yeah. You give him Venice back. That's something. That's what he'd like. Yeah. So this sounds lovely, but Rudolph spends the festive season brooding darkly. His hatred of the Kaiser has now reached absolute fever.
制服？是的。你把威尼斯还给他。那是一回事。那是他想要的。是的。所以这听起来很可爱，但鲁道夫在节日期间阴郁地沉思。他对凯撒的仇恨现在已经达到了绝对的狂热。
Basically, since the Kaiser went back to Berlin, Berlin newspapers have just been mercilessly mocking the Austrian army. And this has driven Rudolph mad. And Rudolph has written to his mate Morris Sepps, the kind of newspaper editor. And he says, I can give you information about that when we went hunting in Styria with Kaiser Wilhelm, a prostitute stole Wilhelm's cufflinks. Do you know who this unexpectedly reminds me of? Is Harold Wilson in 1974? Really?
基本上，自从凯撒回到柏林，柏林的报纸就一直在无情地嘲笑奥地利军队。这让鲁道夫发疯了。鲁道夫写信给他的朋友莫里斯·塞普斯，那种报纸编辑。他说：“当我们在施泰尔马克与威廉皇帝打猎时，一个妓女偷了威廉的袖扣，我可以给你提供相关信息。”你知道这出人意料地让我想起了谁吗？是1974年的哈罗德·威尔逊。真的吗？
releasing mad stories to the press. Yes, I can see that, actually. Clearly made up. Yeah. Well, do you think this is made up, or do you think a prostitue? I think the Kaiser is precisely the kind of man who might have his cufflinks stolen by a lady of the night. No? Yeah, I suppose.
向媒体发布疯狂的故事。是的，我确实能看出来。显然是编造的。嗯，你认为这是编造的，还是你认为一个妓女……我认为凯撒正是那种可能会被夜店女郎偷走袖扣的人。不是吗？是的，我想。
He'd be an unpopular customer. he wouldn't be a great tipper. And in revenge, his escort would steal items of his personal apparel, hoping to blackmail him later. Anyway, Rudolph sends this in this letter and says, I want you to hold on to this. If the Berlin press continues slagging me off, you can print it. And then a couple of days later, he writes again to this editor and he says, I feel the storm clouds are gathering over Austria. In international politics, there is a temporary quiet, the dangers of the danger of
他会是一个不受欢迎的顾客。他不会是一个慷慨的小费给付者。作为报复，他的陪同人员会偷走他的个人服装，希望以后勒索他。总之，鲁道夫在信中写道：“我希望你保留这个。如果柏林媒体继续抨击我，你可以把它印出来。”然后几天后，他再次写信给这位编辑，他说：“我感到风暴云正在奥地利上空聚集。在国际政治中，有一种暂时的平静，来自塞尔维亚的危险……”
threatening us from Serbia. Wow, that's a little preview what's coming. I postponed for the moment, but this uncanny stillness gives me the impression of calm before the storm. It can't go on like this. That's my consolation. And this editor writes back and says,
哇，那是对即将发生的事情的小预告。我暂时推迟了，但这种不可思议的寂静给了我暴风雨前平静的感觉。不能再这样下去了。这是我的安慰。这位编辑回信说，
you're not feeling good. That's a shame. I think you're brilliant. The future is yours. You never tire, unlike so many other people. And it's because our crown prince never tires that we still believe in a great, glorious, free and prosperous Austria.
你感觉不太好。真遗憾。我认为你很出色。未来是你的。你从不疲倦，不像其他许多人。正是因为我们的皇储从不疲倦，我们仍然相信一个伟大、光荣、自由和繁荣的奥地利。
So basically sucking up to Rudolph to try to modify him. The very end of the year, Rudolph and Stephanie, his wife, they go to a place now called Opatia, but at the time called Abatia,
所以基本上是在讨好鲁道夫以试图改变他。年底，鲁道夫和他的妻子斯蒂芬妮去了现在叫奥帕蒂亚的地方，但当时叫阿巴齐亚，
which was on the Adriatic, it's on the Croatian coast. It was the can or the Santeropé of the Austro-Hungarian Empire. So palm trees, hotels, sort of tea lounges, all of this.
它在亚得里亚海，在克罗地亚海岸。它是奥匈帝国的戛纳或圣特罗佩。所以有棕榈树、酒店、茶室，所有这些。
Rudolph doesn't like it. He finds it very boring. He comes back early to Vienna. It's not very Gothic, is it? No, it's not very gothic. It's very dull, as far as he's concerned. And he also finds his wife very dull. He comes back to Vienna.
鲁道夫不喜欢它。他觉得它很无聊。他提前回到了维也纳。这不太哥特，是吗？不，这不太哥特。就他而言，这很无聊。他也觉得他的妻子很无聊。他回到维也纳。
He finds, as usual, there have been meetings of the army command without him, which he's very annoyed by. They didn't invite him because they thought he was on holiday. Then they're into the carnival season. Now, because the Austrian court are still mourning the death of Kaiser's father, the previous summer, court sort of regulations forbid them from going to balls. So what that means is they have to just give a series of dinners
他发现，像往常一样，军队指挥部在没有他的情况下开了会，这让他非常恼火。他们没邀请他，因为他们以为他在度假。然后他们进入了狂欢节季节。现在，因为奥地利宫廷仍在哀悼前一年夏天凯撒父亲的去世，宫廷规定禁止他们参加舞会。所以这意味着他们只能举办一系列晚宴
for visiting dignitaries, royalty, aristocracy and so on. Rudolph again finds this very boring, but the one consolation is that he can resume his affair with Mary Vetsera. And the key date here is the 13th of January, and we know this from Mary's letter the next day to her old governess. She said, I must make a confession. I was with him yesterday evening from seven till nine. We both lost our heads.
招待来访的政要、皇室成员、贵族等等。鲁道夫再次觉得这很无聊，但唯一的安慰是他可以恢复与玛丽·维采拉的恋情。这里的关键日期是1月13日，我们从玛丽第二天写给她前家庭教师的信中得知了这一点。她说：“我必须坦白。我昨天晚上从七点到九点和他在一起。我们都失去了理智。”
Now we belong to each other body and soul. On Saturday, I hope to get away from a ball, and then I will rush back to him. So we belong to each other body and soul. We lost our heads. We all know what happened between seven and nine that evening. And that same day, she went to the most expensive jewelry shop in Vienna, and she ordered a gold cigarette case inscribed with the date of their Trist the night before the 13th of January,
“现在我们身心都属于彼此。周六，我希望能从舞会中溜出来，然后我会赶回他身边。”所以我们身心都属于彼此。我们失去了理智。我们都知道那天晚上七点到九点之间发生了什么。同一天，她去了维也纳最昂贵的珠宝店，订购了一个金烟盒，上面刻着他们前一天晚上幽会的日期——1月13日，
and she wants to give it to the crown prince to remember the occasion. And my guess is that it was probably around now that he floated seriously the idea that he had mentioned a few weeks earlier, which she mentioned to her governess, the idea that one day they will be discovered, that we will go to a happy place that nobody knows, and then we will enter death together. And this is not the first time that Rudolph has mentioned this to a woman, because we know that he had mentioned it to his regular mistress, Mitzie Kaspar, before Christmas, and she had laughed at him and thought it was a joke. I thought that there were... In versions I've read of this, she goes to the police and tells them,
她想把它送给皇储以纪念这个场合。我的猜测是，可能就在这个时候，他认真地提出了他几周前提到过的想法，也就是她告诉她家庭教师的想法，即有一天他们会被发现，我们将去一个无人知晓的快乐地方，然后我们将一起步入死亡。这不是鲁道夫第一次向女人提到这一点，因为我们知道他在圣诞节前向他的固定情妇米齐·卡斯帕提到过，她嘲笑他，认为这是一个玩笑。我以为有……在我读过的版本中，她去了警察局告诉他们，
and the police refuse to listen to her because she's just a prostitute. Is that not true? Yeah, I don't know how true that is. So I've seen that online, and I've seen that repeated in kind of general histories. But I'm not convinced how true that, I mean, it may be true. Maybe listeners who, particularly Austrian listeners who might have read German language versions of this, may be more familiar with it. But in, for example, Frederick Morton's book, which is kind of day by day,
警察拒绝听她的，因为她只是个妓女。那不是真的吗？是的，我不知道那有多真实。所以我已经在网上看到了，我也在一般的历史书中看到了重复。但我并不确信那有多真实，我的意思是，它可能是真的。也许听众，特别是可能读过德语版本的奥地利听众，可能更熟悉它。但在弗雷德里克·莫顿的书里，那是按天记录的，
there's no mention of this, just mentions her laughing at him. There's a slight disconnect actually between laughing at somebody because you think they're joking. Yeah, and then going to the police. And then going to the police. Is it a better story if they go to the police? She goes to the police?
没有提到这一点，只是提到她嘲笑他。嘲笑某人因为你认为他们在开玩笑，与去警察局之间实际上存在轻微的脱节。然后去警察局。如果他们去警察局，这是一个更好的故事吗？她去了警察局？
Maybe it is a better story. What we do know for certain is that Mary didn't laugh. Mary is not a joker in that way and she takes her relationship with the Crown Prince incredibly seriously. She sees it in these very overwrought terms. But of course, this is again, And what we don't know, we don't know what they said to each other.
也许这是一个更好的故事。我们确定知道的是玛丽没有笑。玛丽不是那种会开玩笑的人，她非常认真地对待她与皇储的关系。她以这些非常过度激动的术语来看待它。但当然，这又是……我们不知道的是，我们不知道他们对彼此说了什么。
We cannot know how much she was coerced. You know, he's 30. He's the crown prince. She's a massive goth, though, isn't she? I mean, you said. She's a massive goth, of course. But how much she enters into this pact, you know, voluntarily, difficult to say. Anyway, Rudolf's friends and acquaintances suspect absolutely nothing.
我们无法知道她受到了多少胁迫。你知道，他30岁。他是皇储。不过她是个超级哥特，不是吗？我的意思是，你说过。她当然是个超级哥特。但她自愿参与这份协议的程度，很难说。总之，鲁道夫的朋友和熟人什么都没怀疑。
That month, he seems calm. He seems untroubled. He seems polite. He goes repeatedly to operettas or to the opera. On the 23rd of January, for example, he goes to see a comedy called the Dandes of Vienna and he's cheered by the audience. He's working on his encyclopedia. He writes an article, one of his many anonymous articles for a monarchist periodical,
那个月，他看起来很平静。他看起来没有烦恼。他看起来很有礼貌。他反复去听轻歌剧或歌剧。例如，1月23日，他去看了一部叫《维也纳的丹德》的喜剧，观众为他欢呼。他正在编写他的百科全书。他写了一篇文章，他为一份保皇派期刊撰写的众多匿名文章之一，
in which he basically says, people should stop going on about Germany and how brilliant Germany is. People should put their faith in Austria, ancient united and undivided. And of course, being a Habsburg, he does a lot of hunting. So he's not quite in his cousin Franz Ferdinand's league. So Franz Ferdinand, his kind of younger cousin and protégé, and sort of a world-class butcher of birds. But Rudolph still, you know, he sees an eagle.
在文中他基本上说，人们应该停止谈论德国以及德国有多么出色。人们应该把信仰放在奥地利身上，古老、统一且不可分割。当然，作为一个哈布斯堡家族的人，他经常打猎。所以他并不完全在他表弟弗朗茨·斐迪南的水平上。所以弗朗茨·斐迪南，他的年轻表弟和门徒，以及某种世界级的鸟类屠夫。但鲁道夫仍然，你知道，他看到一只鹰。
He likes to shoot it. So he shot three eagles on the 20th, three more on the 21st and five deer on the 23rd of January. On the 24th of January, so Thursday the 24th, he now has less than a week to live, by the way. Bratfish drove him to meet Mary by the Prater Park. Again, it was very cold, very deserted, no one there. And they fixed a date at this meeting.
他喜欢射杀它。所以他在1月20日射杀了三只鹰，21日又射杀了三只，23日射杀了五只鹿。1月24日，也就是1月24日星期四，顺便说一句，他离去世不到一周了。布拉特菲什开车送他去普拉特公园见玛丽。同样，天气很冷，非常荒凉，那里没有人。他们在这次会面上定了一个日期。
They said, let's go to the Myeling Hunting Lodge on Monday, because he said, I'm going there anyway with some friends to do some more hunting. And that evening, the evening of Thursday, the 24th, he went to the court opera and he sat beside his father in the imperial box. They were spotted deep in a very serious conversation, but nobody knows, or we'll ever know what was said. On Friday the 25th, he has five days to live. He goes hunting again on the banks of the Danube.
他们说，周一去迈耶林狩猎小屋，因为他说，我反正要和一些朋友去那里再打猎。那天晚上，1月24日星期四晚上，他去了宫廷歌剧院，坐在皇家包厢里他父亲的旁边。他们被发现正在进行一场非常严肃的谈话，但没有人知道，或者永远不会知道说了什么。1月25日星期五，他还有五天可活。他又去多瑙河岸边打猎。
He shot 26 ducks, seems like a lot, actually. Then he went back to town. He went to Hodex taxidermist shop on the Maria Hilfusrasa, where they'd been stuffing his eagles for him. God. I mean, the whole empty fairgrounds, stuff the taxidermist. It's brilliant. It's got it all.
他射杀了26只鸭子，看起来确实很多。然后他回到了城里。他去了玛丽亚希尔夫大街上的霍德克斯标本制作店，他们一直在为他制作鹰的标本。天哪。我的意思是，整个空荡荡的游乐场，塞满标本制作师。这太棒了。它应有尽有。
I was thinking about this. I think this would be a brilliant Alfred Hitchcock film. David Lynch would enjoy it as well. Yeah. There are lots of directors who would do really, really good, different versions of this. Yeah. Christopher Nolan would cast Killian Murphy, surely, as Crown Prince Rudolph. A young Killian Murphy.
我一直在想这个。我认为这将是一部出色的阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克电影。大卫·林奇也会喜欢的。是的。有很多导演会制作非常、非常好的、不同版本的电影。是的。克里斯托弗·诺兰肯定会选基里安·墨菲饰演鲁道夫皇储。年轻的基里安·墨菲。
Yeah. Michael Cain is his father. Yeah. I was about to say Tom Hard. Tom Hardy is the coachman, surely. Yes. Tom Hardy is Bradfish. Surely everyone wants to see that.
是的。迈克尔·凯恩是他父亲。是的。我正要说汤姆·哈迪。汤姆·哈迪肯定是车夫。是的。汤姆·哈迪是布拉特菲什。肯定每个人都想看那个。
That would be the spin-off series. Bradfish. Yeah. He's solving crimes with Sigma. He's solving crimes with Freud. Fantastic. All right. So he's gone to the taxidermist shop.
那将是衍生系列。布拉特菲什。是的。他和西格玛一起破案。他和弗洛伊德一起破案。太棒了。好吧。所以他去了标本制作店。
Then he goes to a painter's studio. I've put the painter in just so I can say his name. His name is Tadeus Adyukovic. And he is a pole, I think, for giving his name. And he's painting Rudolph on horseback, showing him as an infantry general. And then he goes to the palace. for dinner. Does the painting, the portrait of Rudolph, start to weep tears? Surely. Yeah, definitely. Of blood. So Saturday, they're 26th, he has four days to live, the same routine.
然后他去了一位画家的工作室。我把画家放进去只是为了能说出他的名字。他的名字叫塔德乌什·阿迪尤科维奇。我想他是个波兰人，因为他的名字。他正在画骑在马上的鲁道夫，展示他作为步兵将军的样子。然后他去了宫殿吃晚饭。鲁道夫的肖像画会开始流泪吗？肯定会。是的，绝对会。流血泪。所以周六，26日，他还有四天可活，同样的例行公事。
And as if to punish him, the fates are mocking him, because that evening there's a court din that's a celebrate of all things, Kaiserville on the second's birthday. So Rudolph has to dress up in his uniform as an honorary colonel of the second Brandenburg Ulan regiment. And this must be a terrible thing for him because he regards the Kaiser as the worst man in history, a dreadful bounder, but he has to sort of smile and make small talk about how brilliant the Kaiser is. The next day, Sunday 27th, there are now three days to go. Same routine, hunting, taxidervous shop, portrait, and then he rushes back to the Hofberg and he changes into civilian clothes and Bratfish drives him to the back entrance, the tradesman's entrance of the Grand Hotel. And there he goes upstairs, up the
仿佛为了惩罚他，命运在嘲笑他，因为那天晚上有一场宫廷晚宴，庆祝凯撒威廉二世的生日。所以鲁道夫必须穿上他作为第二勃兰登堡枪骑兵团荣誉上校的制服。这对他来说一定是一件可怕的事情，因为他认为凯撒是历史上最糟糕的人，一个可怕的无赖，但他必须微笑并进行关于凯撒有多出色的闲聊。第二天，周日27日，还有三天。同样的例行公事，打猎，标本制作店，肖像画，然后他赶回霍夫堡，换上平民服装，布拉特菲什开车送他到后门，大酒店的贸易商入口。然后他上楼，上
backstess Larrish is sweeter. She's come back from Bohemia. She's the go-between once again with Mary. Then he goes back into the coach. They go off to the Prata, the deserted park. Mary is waiting there in a coach of her own. Again, a hurried meeting with Mary to finalise the plans for tomorrow. And then back to the palace.
拉里什伯爵夫人更甜美。她从波希米亚回来了。她再次成为与玛丽之间的中间人。然后他回到马车里。他们去了普拉特，那个荒凉的公园。玛丽在自己的马车里等着。又是与玛丽的一次匆忙会面，以敲定明天的计划。然后回到宫殿。
Another quick change into another German uniform because he has to go to another reception for the Kaiser's birthday. Oh, God. They want to reshoots himself. Imagine your most hated enemy, having to dress up in uniforms and go to... It's like a nightmare, right? Or a Greek punishment. It's like Sisyphus had it easy.
又快速换上另一套德国制服，因为他必须去参加凯撒生日的另一场招待会。哦，天哪。他们想让他自杀。想象一下你最痛恨的敌人，不得不穿上制服去……这就像一场噩梦，对吧？或者是一种希腊式的惩罚。这就像西西弗斯过得很轻松。
So he has to go to a reception at the German embassy for the Kaiser's birthday. Now, at this reception is his father and also his wife, Crown Princess Stephanie, who's looking very elegant, and his lover. Mary Vetsera. So they're all there. Is their relationship now common knowledge? Does Stephanie know, do we think? I don't know.
所以他必须去德国大使馆参加凯撒生日的招待会。现在，在这个招待会上，有他的父亲，还有他的妻子，斯蒂芬妮皇储妃，她看起来非常优雅，还有他的情人。玛丽·维采拉。所以他们都在那里。他们的关系现在是众所周知的吗？我们认为斯蒂芬妮知道吗？我不知道。
We just don't know. So there is a moment. Supposed it's a moment. I think this is made up, actually, where Stephanie and Mary came face to face, and there was apparently a little pause before Mary Kurtzid just too, she waited just too long,
我们只是不知道。所以有一个时刻。假设这是一个时刻。我认为这是编造的，实际上，斯蒂芬妮和玛丽面对面，显然有一个小小的停顿，在玛丽行屈膝礼之前，她等得太久了，
like a little gesture of disrespect to Rudolph's wife. Well, that's what people said, afterwards, but I suspect at the time. Yes, it sounds retrospective. It's retrospective, yeah, exactly. Now, Rudolph is very pale and quiet at this reception, partly because he hates the Kaiser, but also maybe for other reasons. At one point he's making small talk with a sculptor called Victor Tilgner,
就像对鲁道夫妻子的一种不尊重的姿态。嗯，那是人们后来说的，但我怀疑当时……是的，这听起来是回顾性的。这是回顾性的，是的，没错。现在，鲁道夫在这次招待会上非常苍白和安静，部分原因是他讨厌凯撒，但也可能有其他原因。有一次他正在和一位叫维克多·蒂尔格纳的雕塑家闲聊，
and later claimed, again, this may be retrospective, that at one point Rudolph gave a kind of shiver or shudder and said to him, this whole uniform is distasteful to me, unbearably heavy, and that that was the only hint of something. But of course that could be just a banal thing. It could be he hates German uniforms. I mean, it really could be heavy.
后来声称，同样，这可能是回顾性的，有一次鲁道夫打了个寒颤，对他说了：“这整套制服让我感到厌恶，沉重得难以忍受。”而那只是某种暗示。但当然，那可能只是一件平庸的事情。可能他讨厌德国制服。我的意思是，它确实可能很重。
He could indeed. I imagine there were a lot of medals. Surely. And epaulettes. Yeah, weighing his shoulders down. He doesn't stay long at this reception, though. By midnight he's gone and he doesn't go back to the palace. He goes to the apartment of his mistress, Mitzi Kaspar,
他确实可以。我想当时一定有很多勋章。当然。还有肩章。是的，压得他肩膀都沉了。不过，他在招待会上没待多久。午夜时分他就离开了，而且他没有回皇宫。他去了他情妇米齐·卡斯帕的公寓，
and they drink champagne laced with cognac. Our favorite drink. Our favorite tipple. A favorite drink, exactly. We'll be drinking that at the rest of his history Christmas party. and Rudolph says to Mitzie tomorrow morning I'm leaving to go hunting forever and Mitzie kind of laughs at him
他们喝着加了干邑白兰地的香槟。我们最喜欢的饮料。我们最喜欢的酒。确实是喜欢的饮料。我们会在《历史的其余部分》圣诞派对上喝这个。鲁道夫对米齐说，明天早上我要去打猎，永远离开。米齐有点嘲笑他，
she doesn't go to the police she laughed and she says to herself this is the kind of mad thing that Rudolph says all the time because he's a bit of a goth he's always saying morbid things like this three o'clock in the morning he leaves her apartment to go back to the Imperial Palace of the Halfburg and there's an old little gesture as he leaves He makes the sign of the cross on her forehead,
她没有报警，她只是笑了笑，心想这又是鲁道夫常说的那种疯话，因为他有点哥特风，总是说这种病态的话。凌晨三点，他离开她的公寓，回到哈布斯堡王朝的皇宫。在他离开时，有一个小小的旧动作，他在她的额头上画了一个十字，
even though he doesn't believe in God. He is told her he doesn't believe in God. We talked about this yesterday, about whether he would have viewed suicide as a sin, but clearly not. So he goes back to the Imperial Palace. He has a couple of hours sleep, and he's up by 7 o'clock in the morning.
尽管他不信上帝。他告诉过她他不信上帝。我们昨天谈过这个问题，关于他是否会把自杀视为一种罪，但显然不是。于是他回到了皇宫。他睡了几个小时，早上7点就起床了。
He goes through his paperwork. He has meetings with officials. At 11 o'clock outside his office, the clock of St. Michael's, which is the chapel next door, sounds the hour. And Rudolph calls in his adjutant, and he says, cancel my appointments, please, for the rest of the morning.
他处理了文书工作。他与官员们开了会。11点钟，在他办公室外，隔壁圣迈克尔教堂的钟声敲响了。鲁道夫叫来他的副官，说，请帮我取消今天上午剩下的所有预约。
I'm going shooting. Now, I'll be back tomorrow. Five o'clock, I'm going to have dinner with the emperor, as agreed. And on his way out of the palace, he stops briefly at his wife's apartment. He says goodbye to Stephanie and to their daughter, Elizabeth, and he repeats this message. I'll be back tomorrow for dinner. So by half-11, he's on his way, and Rudolph has left the palace.
我要去打猎。明天我会回来。五点钟，我还要按照约定和皇帝共进晚餐。在离开皇宫的路上，他在妻子的公寓短暂停留。他向斯蒂芬妮和他们的女儿伊丽莎白告别，并重复了这条信息。我明天会回来吃晚饭。所以到了11点半，他已经在路上了，鲁道夫离开了皇宫。
Now, meanwhile, Mary Vetsera and Countess Larrish have already left the Vetsera family mansion, which is on the Silesiana gasser in Vienna. They told Mary's mother they were going shopping, which they've said so many times at 10.30. But once they got into the cab, they changed the address. They went to the Hofberg Palace, back entrance again. Once again, Rudolf's coachman, Mr. Bratfish, played by Tom Hardy, is waiting. And he takes them out of the city. So the carriage rolls out of the city and they go into the Vienna woods and they stop beside
与此同时，玛丽·维采拉和拉里什伯爵夫人已经离开了位于维也纳西里西亚街的维采拉家族宅邸。她们告诉玛丽的母亲她们要去购物，这在10点半时她们已经说过很多次了。但一上出租车，她们就改了地址。她们去了霍夫堡皇宫的后门。鲁道夫的车夫布拉特菲什先生（由汤姆·哈迪饰演）再次在那里等候。他把她们带出了城。马车驶出城市，进入维也纳森林，停在
an inn called the Red Barn, the Routers Stardel, which is closed for the winter. Again, a very gothic scene that's abandoned inn. People are always being murdered in red barns, aren't they? Yeah, right. Good spot. So they wait for 20 minutes in the cold by this inn, and then they see a man and a fur-collared coat coming through the woods towards them, and this is Crown Prince Rudolph. It's such a great film.
一家叫“红谷仓”的旅馆旁，那家旅馆冬天关门了。这又是一个非常哥特式的场景，那座废弃的旅馆。人们总是在红谷仓被谋杀，不是吗？是的，没错。观察得好。于是他们在寒冷中在那家旅馆旁等了20分钟，然后他们看到一个穿着毛领大衣的男人穿过树林向他们走来，这就是皇储鲁道夫。这真是一部伟大的电影。
It is. Isn't it? Be amazing. Of course, he's coming through the mist or whatever. It comes through the trees and he gets into their carriage. His own carriage that brought him out of the city is now going back to the city being tailed, as always, by the police. So the police always followed him. So they've shaken off the police now.
确实。不是吗？太棒了。当然，他穿过迷雾什么的。他穿过树林，上了他们的马车。他自己那辆把他带出城的马车现在正返回城里，像往常一样被警察跟踪。所以警察总是跟着他。现在他们已经甩掉了警察。
Now he's shaken off the police. So he and Mary and Bratfish drive on together towards his hunting lodge at Myeling, which is about 20 miles southeast of Vienna. And they arrive roundabout sunset. That's about 5 o'clock. Of course they do. Of course. It's the ravens flock around the gatehouse. It's a really cold, dark evening.
现在他甩掉了警察。于是他和玛丽以及布拉特菲什一起开车前往他位于迈耶林的狩猎小屋，那里距离维也纳东南约20英里。他们在日落时分左右到达。大约是5点钟。当然他们会那样。当然。乌鸦在门房周围盘旋。这是一个非常寒冷、黑暗的夜晚。
The servants have lit the fires in the hunting lodge. Here they will be alone, well alone except for all the servants, until the next day. But back in the city, Countess Larish, who has engineered all this, has this flash of revelation. And we absolutely don't know why. Is it something that Mary said before she left? Is it something that Rudolph said in the last few days that has been, you know, praying on her mind or who knows? But at lunchtime, once she'd seen Mary off, she went back to the Vetsara Mansion and she asked to see Mary's mother and she said, I've lost your daughter.
仆人们在狩猎小屋里生了火。在这里，他们将独处，嗯，除了所有的仆人，直到第二天。但在城里，策划了这一切的拉里什伯爵夫人突然有了一种启示。我们完全不知道为什么。是玛丽离开前说了什么吗？还是鲁道夫过去几天里说了什么一直萦绕在她心头，或者谁知道呢？但在午餐时间，送走玛丽后，她回到维采拉宅邸，要求见玛丽的母亲，她说，我弄丢了你的女儿。
I don't know where she is. I'm worried about her. And that afternoon, one of Mary's uncles, Alexander Baltazzi, went to see the police commissioner of the and he said, we've lost Mary, we've lost the 17-year-old baroness, can you help us find her? And eventually he said to the police commission, look, we think she's gone off with Crown Prince Rudolph. And the Commissioner said, well, come on, I mean, she's gone off with Crown Prince Rudolph, we're hardly going to launch a massive police investigation.
我不知道她在哪里。我很担心她。那天下午，玛丽的一位叔叔亚历山大·巴尔塔齐去见了警察局长，他说，我们弄丢了玛丽，我们弄丢了那位17岁的女男爵，你能帮我们找到她吗？最后他对警察局长说，看，我们认为她和皇储鲁道夫私奔了。局长说，好吧，我是说，她和皇储鲁道夫私奔了，我们难道还要发起大规模的警察调查吗？
For one thing, we are constitutionally barred from investigating the Imperial family. But for another, what are you so stressed about? The Crown Prince has loads of affairs. Clearly, Mary Vetsera is one of his mistresses. She's 17 years old. She knows what she's doing. You know, she's quite racy. She's mature beyond her years.
首先，宪法禁止我们调查皇室成员。其次，你到底在紧张什么？皇储有很多风流韵事。显然，玛丽·维采拉只是他的情妇之一。她17岁了。她知道自己在做什么。你知道，她挺时髦的。她比同龄人成熟。
These things happen. What are you worried about? Yeah, what's the worst that could happen? What's the worst that could happen? Well, we will find out the answer to that question after the break. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers. The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK.
这种事常有。你担心什么？是的，最坏的情况会是什么？最坏的情况会是什么？好吧，休息过后我们就会找到这个问题的答案。嘿，我是来自Gollhangers的迈克尔和汉娜。《历史的其余部分》。本集由英国癌症研究中心赞助。
What if your immune system could learn to recognize cancer cells? That's immunotherapy. One type is car T cell therapy. T cells are your body's watchmen, and doctors can now extract these and reprogram them to spot cancer. Car T cells, they've started showing this real promise in treating cancers of the blood like leukemia, because unlike most cancers,
如果你的免疫系统能学会识别癌细胞会怎样？这就是免疫疗法。其中一种是CAR-T细胞疗法。T细胞是你身体的守卫，医生现在可以提取这些细胞并重新编程，让它们发现癌症。CAR-T细胞在治疗白血病等血液癌症方面已经显示出真正的希望，因为与大多数癌症不同，
blood cancer cells, they float around separately, and that makes it easier for car T cells to see. them out and destroy them. And now, Cancer Research UK-funded scientists are designing CAR-T cells that can tackle solid tumors too, making them tougher so they can survive a more crowded and hostile cancer environment. Now, these approaches are experimental, but they do start to show where treatment might go next.
血液癌细胞是四处漂浮的，这使得CAR-T细胞更容易发现并摧毁它们。现在，英国癌症研究中心资助的科学家们正在设计能够应对实体瘤的CAR-T细胞，使它们更强韧，以便在更拥挤、更恶劣的癌症环境中生存。这些方法目前是实验性的，但它们确实开始展示治疗的未来方向。
And over the past 50 years, Cancer Research UK's pioneering work has helped to double cancer survival in the UK. I mean, this shows you how far research can take us. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research. breakthroughs and how you can support them, visit cancer researchuk.org forward slash rest is science. Gregus believes in the art of living in choosing the pleasurable over the practical. It's why we craft our premium vodka in France using pure spring water from Jenzac.
在过去的50年里，英国癌症研究中心的开创性工作帮助英国的癌症生存率翻了一番。我的意思是，这展示了研究能带我们走多远。有关英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究突破以及如何支持他们的更多信息，请访问cancerresearchuk.org/restiscience。Gregus相信生活艺术，选择享乐而非实用。这就是为什么我们在法国使用来自Jenzac的纯净泉水酿造我们的优质伏特加。
And why you hear the celebratory club of our quirk reminding us to make every martini cocktail count. So go on and make every moment count. Because there's no better time than now. Gregus, make time wait. Cip responsibly. Hello, everybody. We have absolutely sensational, spectacular, stupendous news about a forthcoming Restis History live show.
这也是为什么你会听到我们瓶盖那庆祝般的“咔哒”声，提醒我们要让每一杯马提尼鸡尾酒都物有所值。所以，继续吧，让每一刻都充满意义。因为没有比现在更好的时机了。Gregus，让时间等待。请理性饮酒。大家好。我们有一个关于即将到来的《历史的其余部分》现场演出的绝对轰动、壮观、惊人的消息。
We do, Dominic. Now, sometimes there are complaints that people in Britain don't know enough about the British Empire that they don't study it in sufficient depth. So we are stepping in to make up for that. We are going to be telling the story of the ultimate Victorian imperial adventure. And that, Dominic, is the Abyssinian expedition of 1868. And it's, well, I don't say it's brilliant, but it's mad, isn't it?
我们确实有，多米尼克。现在，有时有人抱怨英国人对大英帝国了解不够，他们研究得不够深入。所以我们正在介入以弥补这一点。我们将讲述维多利亚时代终极帝国冒险的故事。多米尼克，那就是1868年的阿比西尼亚远征。而且，嗯，我不能说它很精彩，但它很疯狂，不是吗？
It is mad. To give people a bit of context, it's an amazing story. The emperor of Abyssinia to Wadros II, he was ignored by Queen Victoria, who didn't answer his letters. So he took some British hostages, and then the British sent an expedition to Abyssinia to attack his capital at Magdala, his kind of mountain citadel. It's an amazing, amazing story, a bonkers story and precisely the kind of thing that we enjoy on the rest is history. Yes, and that I think the entire country could profit from hearing about. So that is what we're
确实很疯狂。给人们一点背景，这是一个惊人的故事。阿比西尼亚皇帝特沃德罗斯二世被维多利亚女王忽视了，她没有回他的信。于是他扣押了一些英国人质，然后英国派出一支远征军前往阿比西尼亚，攻击他的首都马格达拉，也就是他的那种山中堡垒。这是一个惊人、惊人的故事，一个疯狂的故事，正是我们在《历史的其余部分》中喜欢的那种故事。是的，而且我认为整个国家都能从听这个故事中获益。所以这就是我们将要
going to be doing. It is, I think, a very flashman kind of a story. Totally. So anyone who enjoys Flashman will enjoy this. And we are going to be doing it at the South Bank Centre in London on the 4th of September. We do have a few tickets for that. We're also doing it on the 5th of September and not to base, but that one is already sold out. So if you want to come, book your tickets for the 4th of September, and you can get them at the rest is history.com.
做的事情。我认为这是一个非常“弗莱什曼”式的故事。完全正确。所以任何喜欢《弗莱什曼》的人都会喜欢这个。我们将于9月4日在伦敦南岸中心进行演出。我们确实还有一些票。我们也会在9月5日演出，虽然不是在同一个地方，但那场已经售罄了。所以如果你想来，请预订9月4日的票，你可以在therestisistory.com上买到。
Hello, everyone, and welcome back to The Rest is History, where it is the early morning of Tuesday on the 29th of January 1889. and we're in the Myeling Hunting Lodge, some 20-odd miles outside Vienna, where two friends of Crown Prince Rudolf, Count Joseph Hoyos, and Prince Philip of Coburg, have arrived for a day's sport. They're going to go out and murder birds. And Dominic, what happens as they approach the hunting lodge? Well, a very sort of gothic or fairy tale scene.
大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》，现在是1889年1月29日星期二的清晨。我们在距离维也纳约20英里的迈耶林狩猎小屋，皇储鲁道夫的两位朋友，约瑟夫·霍约斯伯爵和科堡的菲利普亲王，已经到达这里进行一天的运动。他们要去猎杀鸟类。多米尼克，当他们接近狩猎小屋时发生了什么？嗯，一种非常哥特式或童话般的场景。
They approached the house, and it's completely, still and silent. And they see that the curtains on the bedroom windows of Rudolph's ground floor apartment are closed. But the servants are up. The servants admit them. And in the billiard room, Crown Prince Rudolph is waiting. So alive and well. He's alive and well. And he seems in good form. Or is he well? Well, he's not well. He's got gonorrhea and he's like off his face on morphine and champagne. But apart from that. And he looks really haggard and gaunt and like looks like a man who's conceived as a murder-suicide pact. But apart from that, he looks like he's in brilliant form.
他们接近房子，那里完全静止且沉默。他们看到鲁道夫一楼公寓卧室的窗帘是拉上的。但仆人们已经起床了。仆人们让他们进去了。在台球室里，皇储鲁道夫正在等候。所以他还活着，很好。他还活着，很好。他看起来状态不错。或者他好吗？嗯，他不好。他得了淋病，而且他因为吗啡和香槟而神志不清。但除此之外。他看起来真的很憔悴、消瘦，看起来像是一个已经构思了谋杀自杀协议的人。但除此之外，他看起来状态极佳。
And has he got kind of little snuffle? Possibly, yes. He's got a bit of a cold, he says. He's got a silk scarf tied very tightly around his neck. He says, I've got a cold, and I probably won't come hunting with you, lads, after all. So you go ahead. I'll sit it out. They had a cup of coffee, and then Hoyos and Kobah go out to do some hunting.
他有没有那种小鼻塞？可能吧，是的。他说他有点感冒。他脖子上紧紧系着一条丝巾。他说，我感冒了，伙计们，我可能还是不跟你们去打猎了。所以你们继续吧。我留下来。他们喝了一杯咖啡，然后霍约斯和科堡就出去打猎了。
And they return at lunchtime, and Rudolph is waiting for them, and he's still in good form. The Prince of Coburg is going back to Vienna straightway the afternoon. And Rudolph says, well, because of this cold, I'm not going to head back when I thought dinner with my father. So please, you know, pass on my message. And he also says to his valet, who's called Loshchek. He says, can you send a telegram to my wife, please, Crown Princess Stephanie? Telegram reads, please tell Papa that I ask his pardon for not appearing at dinner. But because of a heavy cold, I wish to avoid the journey this afternoon.
他们在午餐时间回来，鲁道夫还在等他们，他状态依然很好。科堡亲王下午直接回维也纳。鲁道夫说，好吧，因为感冒，我不打算按原计划回去和我父亲吃晚饭了。所以请传达我的口信。他还对他的贴身男仆洛什切克说。他说，请帮我给我的妻子斯蒂芬妮皇储妃发个电报好吗？电报写着，请告诉爸爸，我请求他原谅我不能出席晚餐。但因为重感冒，我想避免今天下午的旅程。
So the Prince of Coburg goes on. off, the telegram has sent. Count Hoyos goes shooting on his own. So I think that's a slightly joyless thing to do, frankly. Anyway, he goes hunting on his own, he goes and shoots loads of birds, and then he comes back to spend the evening with Rudolph to have dinner with Rudolph. And they have, it's very rested history of Christmas party, actually. They have paté de foie gras, they have venison, they have roast beef, red wine,
于是科堡亲王离开了，电报也发出了。霍约斯伯爵独自去打猎。坦率地说，我认为那是一件相当无趣的事情。无论如何，他独自去打猎，射杀了很多鸟，然后回来和鲁道夫共度夜晚，和鲁道夫一起吃晚饭。他们吃得，实际上非常像《历史的其余部分》的圣诞派对。他们有鹅肝酱、鹿肉、烤牛肉、红酒，
and then they have a sort of leisurely smoke. and they talk about the latest army legislation which has been held up in the parliament in Budapest because of wrangling with the Hungarians. And Rudolf is clearly in quite good form. He's coming up with some great banter. He says it's much easier to deal with gondogs than with Hungarian politicians. And Hoyas thinks this is absolutely hilarious. And says afterwards, he turned on me the whole beguiling force of his personality.
然后他们悠闲地抽了支烟。他们谈论了最近在布达佩斯议会中因与匈牙利人争执而搁置的陆军立法。鲁道夫显然状态相当好。他开了一些很棒的玩笑。他说，处理匈牙利政客比处理猎犬容易多了。霍约斯觉得这绝对滑稽。事后他说，他对我展现了他那迷人个性的全部力量。
So actually, I mean, the mad thing is that Rudolph hates the Kaiser, because this is the kind of banter the Kaiser would very much enjoy. Yeah, it is. They don't think his mother would approve. No. See, she loves Hungarian. Exactly. Anyway, at 9 o'clock, Hoyos says, right, I'm turning in now.
所以实际上，疯狂的是鲁道夫讨厌皇帝，因为这是皇帝会非常喜欢的玩笑。是的，确实。他们认为他的母亲不会赞同。不。你看，她热爱匈牙利。确实。无论如何，9点钟，霍约斯说，好了，我现在要休息了。
Hoyos is going to spend the night in guest quarters in a converted farm cottage, which is about 500 meters from the main house. And as soon as Hoyos has gone down the path, the door of Rudolph's bedroom opens, and out comes Mary Vetsera. and she has been hiding in Rudolph's bedroom all this time. And because she's been hiding in the bedroom, and they've been afraid to send in food to her because Hoyas would notice. So she's starving.
霍约斯将在距离主屋约500米的一间改建的农舍客房里过夜。霍约斯刚沿着小路走开，鲁道夫卧室的门就开了，玛丽·维采拉走了出来。她一直躲在鲁道夫的卧室里。因为她一直躲在卧室里，他们不敢给她送食物，因为霍约斯会注意到。所以她饿坏了。
So Loshchek, the valet, brings her cold venison, and he lights a fire in the billiard room. He brings champagne from the cellar. And he calls for bratfish, the coachman. He's still hanging around. Alia in the chat points out that bratfish means gris. So I think that's a terrible surname, frankly. He's called grilled fish.
于是男仆洛什切克给她拿来了冷鹿肉，并在台球室生了火。他从地窖里拿来了香槟。他叫来了车夫布拉特菲什。他还在附近徘徊。聊天室里的阿利亚指出，布拉特菲什的意思是“烤鱼”。坦率地说，我认为那是一个糟糕的姓氏。他叫“烤鱼”。
That's his name. I think we've established it's a ludicrous name. So Bratfish sits on the stool in the corner of the billiard room, and he sings and whistles songs of old Vienna while they're eating their dinner, Mary and Rudolf. That sounds incredibly annoying. Right. Can't you make him shut up?
那是他的名字。我想我们已经确定这是一个荒谬的名字。所以布拉特菲什坐在台球室角落的凳子上，当玛丽和鲁道夫吃晚饭时，他唱着并吹着老维也纳的歌曲。这听起来令人难以置信地烦人。没错。你不能让他闭嘴吗？
Some bloke called Mr. Grilled Fish turns up and whistles, how you? it's the last thing you want especially in your last night spoiler how do you want a special last hours they wonder if they shot themselves right so they sit up very late Loshchek the man's servant
一个叫“烤鱼先生”的家伙出现并吹口哨，怎么回事？这是你最不想听到的，尤其是在你最后一晚的时候。剧透一下，你怎么会想要特别的最后几个小时？他们想知道他们是否自杀了，对吧？所以他们坐得很晚。男仆洛什切克
he turns in at two o'clock but he doesn't sleep for very long because at half past six he's woken by footsteps he looks up and this would really freak you out he looks up and standing over him is the sepical figure of Crown Prince Rudolf in a dressing gown and a silk scarf looking very pale.
他在两点钟休息，但他没睡多久，因为在六点半，他被脚步声吵醒了。他抬头看，这真的会让你吓坏，他抬头看到站在他上方的是皇储鲁道夫那阴沉的身影，穿着晨衣，系着丝巾，脸色非常苍白。
So Rudolph standing over Loschek says, I want you to call me for breakfast in an hour. And he also says, tell Bratfish to have the horses ready. And then he walks back to his bedroom, a bizarre detail, this whistling one of Bratfish's tunes. So he walks back and he closes the door behind him. Now, Loshchek at this point, he gets dressed. He's about about three hours sleep or something.
所以站在洛什切克上方的鲁道夫说，我要你一小时后叫我吃早餐。他还说，告诉布拉特菲什把马准备好。然后他走回卧室，这是一个离奇的细节，吹着布拉特菲什的曲子之一。于是他走回去，关上了身后的门。现在，洛什切克此时穿好衣服。他只睡了大约三个小时左右。
get stressed and he goes to tell the kitchen staff, get up, come on, sort yourselves out, start getting breakfast ready. And at 7.30, as instructed, he knocks on the Crown Prince's door. And this is the scene with which we opened the first episode. This tremendous scene. Loshchev knocks and he knocks again. He keeps knocking. He calls your imperial highness.
穿好衣服，他去告诉厨房工作人员，起床，快点，整理好自己，开始准备早餐。7点半，按照指示，他敲了皇储的门。这就是我们第一集开头的场景。这个惊人的场景。洛什切克敲门，又敲了一次。他不停地敲。他喊道，皇储殿下。
He runs upstairs and then there's a spiral staircase at the back that goes down to a back door of Rudolph's apartment. and he knocks on the back door again, no reply. Loshchek is becoming quite anxious now because Rudolph is a famously light sleeper. And the dogs started barking. So it's a slightly chaotic scene that hunting dogs are barking because of the knocking. And Loshchek has got into a massive panic. He comes back to the front door.
他跑上楼，后面有一个螺旋楼梯通往鲁道夫公寓的后门。他再次敲后门，没有回应。洛什切克现在变得非常焦虑，因为鲁道夫以睡眠浅而闻名。狗开始叫了。所以这是一个有点混乱的场景，猎犬因为敲门声而狂吠。洛什切克陷入了巨大的恐慌。他回到前门。
He gets a log from the fire and starts hammering on the door with this log. Bratfish, the coachman, joins him. Count Hoyos has come up from his cottage to find out what's going on. And then as if that's not enough, the Prince of Coburg had gone back to Vienna, he now turns up as well because he's come back to do some more hunting. They're all completely shocked and confounded by the scene. And they say to Loshcheque, okay, break down the door.
他从火堆里拿了一根木头，开始用这根木头猛敲门。车夫布拉特菲什加入了他的行列。霍约斯伯爵从他的小屋上来查看发生了什么事。然后，如果这还不够，已经回维也纳的科堡亲王现在也出现了，因为他回来想再打猎。他们都被眼前的景象完全震惊和困惑了。他们对洛什切克说，好吧，破门。
And this is the point, he's now sobbing with worry. And this is the point when he says to them, I have something to tell you. Baroness Mary Vetsara has been staying with the Crown Prince. And then this is the point when Hoyos and Coburg go into the billiard room. and they have the sort of little conference and eventually they come out and they basically say
这就是重点，他现在因为担心而啜泣。这就是他告诉他们的时候，我有话要对你们说。玛丽·维采拉女男爵一直和皇储待在一起。然后这就是霍约斯和科堡走进台球室的时候。他们进行了某种小会议，最后他们出来，基本上说
well even so fine okay we're men of the world break down the door and Loshchek hacks at the door he hacks at the panels as you described in that reading that you did for the first episode the whole becomes this kind of gash
好吧，即便如此，好吧，我们是见过世面的人，破门吧。洛什切克用斧头砍门。他砍着门板，就像你在第一集读的那段中所描述的那样，整个门变成了一个缺口。
and he's able to look through and he drops the axe in horror inside it's total darkness he can see the air is very heavy with smoke but he can see two people lying on or near, it's really not clear from the descriptions, the bed. One of them is Mary. She's stretched out on the bed.
他能够看进去，他惊恐地丢下了斧头。里面一片漆黑，他能感觉到空气中弥漫着浓重的烟味，但他能看到两个人躺在床上或床边，描述中真的不清楚。其中一个是玛丽。她伸展在床上。
Her hands are clasping a rose, and there's blood on the sheets around her head. And the other is Crown Prince Rudolph. He is kind of slumped against or leaning on a bedside table in front of a mirror, and there is blood trickling from his mouth. And it is absolutely obvious that they are both dead. And for a moment, the men outside are paralyzed with horror, and nobody dares to go in. And eventually, Hoyos says, okay, Bratfish, I need you to drive me to Barden Station, which is the nearest railway station.
她的双手紧握着一朵玫瑰，她头部的床单上有血迹。另一个是皇储鲁道夫。他以某种方式瘫倒在镜子前的床头柜上，或者靠在上面，有血从他的嘴里流出。很明显他们都死了。有一瞬间，外面的男人们被恐惧惊呆了，没有人敢进去。最后，霍约斯说，好吧，布拉特菲什，我需要你开车送我去巴登车站，那是最近的火车站。
They get to Barden Station, and he has to go into the stationmaster and say, something terrible has happened at Crown Prince Rudolf's Hunting Lodge. I must get to Vienna instantly. And the stationmaster agrees to stop the express train from Trieste, and Hoyos climbs on board. So at 9.50 he is in Vienna and within about 25 minutes he has reached the Hofberg, the Imperial Palace. And here he completely loses his nerve. He doesn't know how he can possibly break this news to the emperor. So he goes to find Cece's Chamberlain, who is called Baron Nopscher, and they say, well, we will tell the empress and then she can tell the emperor. So Cecee, Elizabeth.
他们到达巴登车站，他不得不走进站长室说，皇储鲁道夫的狩猎小屋发生了可怕的事情。我必须立即赶往维也纳。站长同意拦截从的里雅斯特开来的特快列车，霍约斯登上了列车。所以9点50分他在维也纳，大约25分钟内他就到达了霍夫堡皇宫。在这里他完全失去了勇气。他不知道该如何向皇帝传达这个消息。于是他去找茜茜的侍从长，名叫诺普舍男爵，他们说，好吧，我们告诉皇后，然后她可以告诉皇帝。所以茜茜，伊丽莎白。
She got up early that morning. She got up at 6.30s she always did. Her days always began with this long bath and then a massage. Then her hair famously long. There was a special maid to comb her hair. Yeah, for two or three hours, learning Greek, all of that. Yeah. Then she would have a herbal tea and she would do some exercises in her private gym.
那天早上她起得很早。她像往常一样6点半起床。她的日子总是从这个长时间的沐浴和按摩开始。然后是她著名的长发。有一个专门的女仆为她梳头。是的，两三个小时，学习希腊语，所有这些。是的。然后她会喝一杯草药茶，并在她的私人健身房做一些运动。
Then she, 10 o'clock had started a Greek lesson with Monsieur Rousseophilos. and they were reading the Iliad together. And at 1045 there was a knock on the door and the lady in waiting said, Baron Nobsther and Count Hoyas wanted to see you urgently. And Elizabeth was furious. You don't interfere with my Greek lessons. But then Baron Nobster came in.
然后她10点钟开始和鲁索菲洛斯先生上希腊语课。他们一起读《伊利亚特》。10点45分，门被敲响了，侍女说，诺普舍男爵和霍约斯伯爵有急事要见你。伊丽莎白很愤怒。你不准打扰我的希腊语课。但随后诺普舍男爵进来了。
She saw the look on his face and she realised something was terribly wrong. Now her husband, Franz Joseph, had been up even longer. Well, he always gets up early, doesn't he? Because he's got an empire to run. Right. He got up at 4 o'clock in the morning from his iron military bed.
她看到他脸上的表情，意识到出了大问题。现在她的丈夫弗朗茨·约瑟夫已经起床更久了。嗯，他总是起得很早，不是吗？因为他有一个帝国要管理。没错。他凌晨4点从他的铁制军用床上起床。
And he'd been washed by his footman. He'd had breakfast at 420. And then he got straight into his paperwork and had his first meetings at 5 o'clock in the morning. And a lot of this had been about the Budapest Parliament and the army bill. As Frederick Morton said, that morning, Franz Joseph did what his ancestors had done before him.
他被他的男仆洗漱完毕。他在4点20分吃了早餐。然后他直接开始处理文书工作，并在凌晨5点进行了第一次会议。其中很多是关于布达佩斯议会和陆军法案的。正如弗雷德里克·莫顿所说，那天早上，弗朗茨·约瑟夫做了他的祖先在他之前所做的事情。
He ruled and overruled with utter confidence, with axiomatic competence, and without the slightest inspiration. Just before 11 o'clock, he went set off to go to see his wife in her apartment. Franz Joseph was looking forward to this because he knew that his wife actually had a prearranged meeting with his confidant, Katerina Schrat, the actress. Katerina Schrat was going to do a drama recital for his wife. And this is brilliant for him because he'll see his two favorite people at once.
他以绝对的自信、公理化的能力，但没有任何灵感地统治和否决。11点前不久，他出发去她的公寓看望他的妻子。弗朗茨·约瑟夫很期待这一点，因为他知道他的妻子实际上已经预先安排了与他的知己、女演员卡特琳娜·施拉特的会面。卡特琳娜·施拉特要为他的妻子做戏剧朗诵。这对他是极好的，因为他可以同时见到他最喜欢的两个人。
And, you know, their little menage, atois, he loves all that. But he gets there and he finds Baron Nopster blocking the door to his wife's apartment. Baron Noxcher's face is streaks with tears and through the door Franz Joseph can hear his wife sobbing and sobbing. So in the next few hours, the news that something terrible has happened races around the city. Crown Prince Rudolf's wife, Stephanie is having a singing lesson and that's interrupted and she is told. And soon after that all the operas, the theatres, the cabarets, the musicals are told to cancel their evening programs with their explanation. And by mid-afternoon, there's a crowd outside the Hofberg.
而且，你知道，他们的小三角关系，他喜欢这一切。但他到了那里，发现诺普舍男爵挡住了他妻子公寓的门。诺普舍男爵的脸上挂满了泪水，透过门，弗朗茨·约瑟夫能听到他的妻子在啜泣。所以在接下来的几个小时里，发生了可怕事情的消息在城里传开了。皇储鲁道夫的妻子斯蒂芬妮正在上声乐课，课程被打断了，她被告知了消息。此后不久，所有的歌剧院、剧院、歌舞表演、音乐剧都被告知取消当晚的节目，并给出了他们的解释。到了下午中期，霍夫堡外聚集了人群。
People know something has happened. There are people talking about Grand Prince Rudolph, but no one knows exactly what it is. And it's actually not until the following morning that the news is confirmed. It's broken by the Vina Tagblatt. Our Crown Prince is dead, says this huge headline. It's reproduced. There's an image of it in Frederick Morton's book, A Nervous Splendor. But what there aren't, there are no details.
人们知道发生了什么事。有人在谈论皇储鲁道夫，但没有人确切知道是什么。直到第二天早上，消息才得到证实。它是由《维也纳日报》发布的。我们的皇储死了，这个巨大的标题写道。它被转载了。弗雷德里克·莫顿的书《神经质的辉煌》中有一张它的图片。但没有的是，没有细节。
of how he died. So the assumption that most people make is he has had a stroke or a heart attack, you know, a freak accident or something, who knows? Throttled by the Kaiser. Yeah, exactly. He's died of apoplexy after the Kaiser's been rude about an Austrian army belt or something of that kind, surely. A bit the obvious explanation, wouldn't it? But not, it's the following evening, the Vina Tagblatt prints the headline, the most horrible truth. And it says, Crown Prince Rudolph was killed by a gunshot, and he fired the pistol himself.
关于他是怎么死的。所以大多数人的假设是他中风或心脏病发作，你知道，一场离奇的事故什么的，谁知道呢？被皇帝勒死了。是的，没错。他死于中风，在皇帝对奥地利陆军法案说了些粗鲁的话之后，肯定是的。这难道不是显而易见的解释吗？但不是，第二天晚上，《维也纳日报》刊登了标题，“最可怕的真相”。它说，皇储鲁道夫是被枪杀的，是他自己扣动了手枪。
I mean, I can't imagine, because it's still a very devoutly Catholic city and country. Yeah. I mean, the impact must be devastating. Exactly. I mean, this is, we said it's the royal scandal to end all royal scandals. I mean, let's try to imagine. I mean, it's not even Prince Harry. It would be implausibly your fellow Aston Villa supporter, Prince William.
我的意思是，我无法想象，因为这仍然是一个非常虔诚的天主教城市和国家。是的。我的意思是，这种影响一定是毁灭性的。确实。我的意思是，这是，我们说过这是终结所有皇室丑闻的皇室丑闻。我的意思是，让我们试着想象一下。我的意思是，这甚至不是哈里王子。这会是难以置信地你的阿斯顿维拉支持者同伴，威廉王子。
Prince William. Yeah. Carrying on with a 17-year-old and having a murder-suicide pact at a hunting lodge in stains. I think it's much worse than that because suicide is no longer framed as a sin. No, it's true. Yeah. You know, it's treated with sympathy and kind of understanding now. But back then, it was a sin. I mean, it endangers your mortal soul in the Habsburgs. it's important to their legitimacy that they are Catholic.
威廉王子。是的。和一个17岁的人鬼混，并在斯坦斯的一个狩猎小屋里进行谋杀自杀协议。我认为这比那糟糕得多，因为自杀不再被视为一种罪。不，这是真的。是的。你知道，现在它被同情和理解了。但在那时，这是一种罪。我的意思是，它危及你的凡人灵魂，在哈布斯堡家族中。他们的合法性很重要的一点是他们是天主教徒。
Completely. They're the guardians of Catholicism. Yeah. You know, they are the absolute, his apostolic majesty, Franz Joseph. You know, it's so important for them as kings of Hungary and as emperors of Austria. Absolutely. So let's actually focus on the imperial family for a second. By the way, one small detail, actually, which I forgot to mention.
完全正确。他们是天主教的守护者。是的。你知道，他是绝对的，他的使徒陛下，弗朗茨·约瑟夫。你知道，作为匈牙利国王和奥地利皇帝，这对他们来说太重要了。绝对。所以让我们关注一下皇室成员。顺便说一句，其实我忘了提一个小细节。
Mary Vetsara's name has never been mentioned in any of those newspaper reports at all. We'll come back to her role in the story in a second. So Franz Joseph spent the first afternoon trying to console his wife along with Katerina Shratt. And then being Franz Joseph, he went back to work. And he worked late that night and he rang by 10 o'clock that night. On the day he heard the news about his son, he was still ringing the Hungarian prime minister to talk about the army bill. The next day he got up at 4 o'clock as usual to start work. But at dawn he had a visitor, the imperial doctor, Professor Hermann Wiedehofer, who had been to Myer.
玛丽·维采拉的名字从未在任何报纸报道中被提及。我们稍后再回到她在故事中的角色。所以弗朗茨·约瑟夫下午的第一时间试图和卡特琳娜·施拉特一起安慰他的妻子。然后作为弗朗茨·约瑟夫，他回去工作了。那天晚上他工作到很晚，直到晚上10点。在他听到关于他儿子的消息的那天，他还在给匈牙利总理打电话谈论陆军法案。第二天他像往常一样在4点起床开始工作。但在黎明时分，他有一位访客，皇家医生赫尔曼·维德霍夫教授，他去过迈耶林。
and it was the first person who basically went into the room to inspect the bodies. And Professor Vidohofer says, I have some pretty bad news. It is clear that the Crown Prince died by his own hand, a gunshot wound to the head. But what is worse, there is no doubt that he killed Mary of Vetsera with the same gun two hours earlier. So actually, this is so interesting. He had killed Mary Vatsera before he appeared at the manservant's bedside. side to say, get my breakfast ready. To ask for breakfast?
他是第一个基本上进入房间检查尸体的人。维德霍夫教授说，我有一些非常糟糕的消息。很明显，皇储是死于自己之手，头部有枪伤。但更糟糕的是，毫无疑问，他在两小时前用同一把枪杀死了玛丽·维采拉。所以实际上，这太有趣了。他在出现在男仆床边说“帮我准备早餐”之前就已经杀死了玛丽·维采拉。去要早餐？
Yeah. So what do you think was going on there? I don't know. Did he ever plan to eat the breakfast, change his mind? Impossible to say. Strange. I mean, everything about this is strange. Let's not deny that.
是的。所以你认为那里发生了什么？我不知道。他曾经计划吃早餐吗，还是改变了主意？无法说。奇怪。我的意思是，关于这一切的一切都很奇怪。我们不要否认这一点。
No. But the worst of it, I think, for Franz Joseph, is what Vida Hova then says. The Crown Prince has left a number of letters. So he's left a letter to his mother, Cece. This is the only letter that was written at the scene of the crime. The other letters were written beforehand. He wrote to his mother, I have no right to go on living. I have killed.
不。但我认为对弗朗茨·约瑟夫来说最糟糕的是维德霍夫随后说的话。皇储留下了几封信。所以他给他的母亲茜茜留了一封信。这是唯一一封在犯罪现场写的信。其他信件是事先写好的。他写给他的母亲，我没有权利继续活下去。我杀了人。
And he asks that he and Mary are buried together at the nearby Abbey of Heiligenkreutz, Holy Cross. He wrote a letter to his sister Valerie beforehand. He said, I advise you, you know, I'm going now. I advise you when our father dies, leave Austria. For what will happen then in Austria is unforeseeable. This is again his kind of existential apocalyptic dread about the Jews. a political outlook for its country. And a shrewd analysis.
他请求他和玛丽一起被埋葬在附近的圣十字修道院。他事先写了一封信给他的妹妹瓦莱丽。他说，我建议你，你知道，我现在要走了。我建议你当我们的父亲去世时，离开奥地利。因为那时奥地利会发生什么不可预见。这又是他那种关于犹太人的存在主义末日恐惧。一种对国家的政治展望。而且是一个精明的分析。
Yeah, I guess so. He wrote a letter to Stephanie, his wife. Dear Stephanie, you are now rid of my presence and annoyance. Be happy in your own way. Take care of the poor little one. She is all that is left of me. He wrote a letter to Loshchek, his valet. Thank you for all the years of service.
是的，我想是这样。他写了一封信给他的妻子斯蒂芬妮。亲爱的斯蒂芬妮，你现在摆脱了我的存在和烦恼。以你自己的方式快乐吧。照顾好那个可怜的小家伙。她是我留下的唯一东西。他写了一封信给他的男仆洛什切克。感谢你多年的服务。
He also wrote letters to his friend, Baron Moritz-Hursh, and to his mistress, Mitzie Caspar. But the contents of those letters is unknown, has never been released. And for his father, the emperor, there was no letter at all, nothing. Oh, dear. And that is the moment when the doctor says that to Franz Joseph, that's the moment when Franz Joseph loses his composure, and he breaks down in tears and he collapses and falls to the ground.
他还写信给他的朋友莫里茨·赫什男爵和他的情妇米齐·卡斯帕。但这些信的内容不得而知，从未公开过。而对于他的父亲，皇帝，根本没有信，什么都没有。哦，亲爱的。这就是医生对弗朗茨·约瑟夫说那番话的时候，也是弗朗茨·约瑟夫失去镇定，泪流满面并瘫倒在地的时候。
And you can absolutely understand why. For a father, that would be... Of course, of course. Devastating. That would be almost the worst blow of all, I think. such kind of posthumous cruelty as well, isn't it? Yeah. So eventually he composes himself
你绝对可以理解为什么。对于一个父亲来说，那将是……当然，当然。毁灭性的。我认为那几乎是所有打击中最糟糕的一个。这种死后的残忍也是，不是吗？是的。所以最后他镇定下来
and he says, where is my son? And Dr. Vidohofer said, well, we've brought the body back to the palace as you ordered, we've dressed him in uniform, we've bandaged his head and we put him in bed. And French Joseph went to his son's bedroom and he stood by his son's body for 15 minutes and silence, kind of vigil for a brother officer, as per the army
他说，我的儿子在哪里？维德霍夫医生说，嗯，我们按照您的命令把尸体带回了皇宫，我们给他穿上了制服，包扎了他的头，把他放在床上。弗朗茨·约瑟夫走进他儿子的卧室，在儿子的尸体旁站了15分钟，沉默着，按照军队的规定，为一位兄弟军官守夜。
regulations. That's always the way with him. And then he said to his aides, we have two priorities. is now. Number one, my son must have a Catholic burial. The Habsburgs have Catholic burials, Catholic funerals, even though he is both a murderer and a suicide. And then secondly, he said, all mention of this girl must be suppressed. Her presence at the scene, her body, even her name must be deleted from the public record. Now, what made this difficult is that the Habsbergs themselves have told the Vetsera family what happened to Mary.
那对他来说总是那样。然后他对他的助手说，我们有两个优先事项。第一，我的儿子必须有天主教葬礼。哈布斯堡家族有天主教葬礼，天主教葬礼，即使他既是谋杀者又是自杀者。然后第二，他说，所有关于这个女孩的提及都必须被压制。她在现场的存在、她的尸体，甚至她的名字都必须从公共记录中删除。现在，这之所以困难，是因为哈布斯堡家族自己已经告诉了维采拉家族玛丽发生了什么事。
Cece herself broke the news to Mary's mother. Now, at the time, the Imperial staff said to Mary's mother, Baroness Elen Vetsera, they said, you have to get out of Vienna. You know, the press will be hounding you. There will be crowds, bane for your blood. People will blame your daughter for this, and you have to get out. And she got on a train to Italy,
茜茜亲自把消息告诉了玛丽的母亲。当时，皇室工作人员对玛丽的母亲埃伦·维采拉女男爵说，你必须离开维也纳。你知道，媒体会纠缠你。会有渴望你鲜血的人群。人们会把这件事归咎于你的女儿，你必须离开。她坐火车去了意大利，
but then she changed her mind halfway, and she came back to the city, and she found that the city police had cordoned off her, townhouse, her mansion, because of the crowds outside. She was in a terrible state. She wanted to go into the house. And eventually the Austrian Prime Minister, Count Tarfa turned up. He was very, I think we described him in the last episode, he's a very suave kind of top hat cigar. And he sort of said, my dear, my dear lady, what a terrible business this is for you. I really do think you should get out of the city and you should keep a very low profile. It's now clear, by the way,
但后来她在半路改变了主意，她回到了城里，发现城市警察封锁了她的联排别墅，她的宅邸，因为外面的人群。她处于一种可怕的状态。她想进屋。最后奥地利总理塔法伯爵出现了。他非常，我想我们在上一集描述过他，他是一个非常温文尔雅、戴着高礼帽抽雪茄的人。他有点说，我亲爱的，我亲爱的女士，这对你来说是一件多么可怕的事情。我真的认为你应该离开这个城市，你应该保持非常低调。顺便说一句，现在很清楚，
that this was a genuine suicide pact because Mary's mother is now given a letter. by Mary. Forgive me for what I have done. I could not resist love. In agreement with him, I wish to be buried by his side of the Alland churchyard. It's actually a slightly different place from the Highly Concord's Abbey, but there you go. I'm happier in death than I was in life. I mean, imagine what that must be like for a mother to read from her daughter. Of course, there's a big issue here for the families now. If Mary and Rudolph are suicides, they cannot be buried in consecrated ground. The emperor, however, gets in touch with Heiligenkroyce Abbey and his staff do anyway, and they say basically, we want you to find room for Mary Vetsara's body. No questions asked,
这是一个真正的自杀协议，因为玛丽的母亲现在收到了一封信。由玛丽写的。原谅我所做的一切。我无法抗拒爱情。与他达成一致，我希望被埋葬在他身边的阿兰德墓地。这实际上是一个与圣十字修道院略有不同的地方，但就是这样。我在死亡中比在生活中更快乐。我的意思是，想象一下一个母亲读到她女儿写的这些话会是什么感觉。当然，现在家庭有一个大问题。如果玛丽和鲁道夫是自杀，他们不能被埋葬在神圣的土地上。然而，皇帝与圣十字修道院取得了联系，他的工作人员也确实这样做了，他们基本上说，我们希望你为玛丽·维采拉的尸体找到空间。不问任何问题，
you must find her a plot. And that same day, Thursday the 31st of January, two of her uncles, the Baltazzi brothers, went to Myeling. They identified her body. A doctor washed the blood off her body and they dressed it in coat and hat in their sort of veil, a boa shoes. You know, remember she's very fashionable. And then an absolutely bizarre scene, Mary's uncles propped her up and walked her out of the hunting lodge as if she was alive and put her in the carriage and sat either side of her. So if anybody's seen the film, Weekend at Bernice, that's what this is. And they even stuck a broomstick up the back of her dress so that it would keep her upright. Because there are all kinds of stories for Sherlock Holmes turns up.
你必须为她找到一块墓地。同一天，1月31日星期四，她的两个叔叔，巴尔塔齐兄弟，去了迈耶林。他们确认了她的尸体。一名医生洗去了她尸体上的血迹，他们给她穿上了外套和帽子，戴上了面纱、围巾和鞋子。你知道，记住她非常时髦。然后是一个绝对离奇的场景，玛丽的叔叔们支撑着她，把她从狩猎小屋里走了出来，就好像她还活着一样，把她放进马车，坐在她两边。所以如果有人看过电影《老板度假》，这就是那个场景。他们甚至在她的裙子后面插了一根扫帚柄，这样她就能保持直立。因为有各种各样的故事，福尔摩斯出现了。
Yes. And so it's the case, aren't there? I don't think he'd have been fooled by that. No, he wouldn't. I mean, this is so Sherlock Holmes, isn't it? It's sort of scandal in Bohemia. Yeah. You know, all of that.
是的。所以就是这个案子，不是吗？我不认为他会被那个骗过。不，他不会。我的意思是，这太福尔摩斯了，不是吗？这是一种波希米亚丑闻。是的。你知道，所有这些。
So the carriage rolled through the night to High Lig and Croyd's Abbey, which is about three miles away. There are loads of police waiting. And only the next morning, when the rain stopped a little bit, they buried Mary. And then the police sent a coded telegram to Vienna just with the words all finished. And that was the end in every way of Mary Vetsera.
于是马车连夜驶向海利格克罗伊茨修道院，那里距离大约三英里。有大批警察在等候。直到第二天早上，雨稍微停了一点，他们才埋葬了玛丽。随后，警方给维也纳发了一封加密电报，内容只有“一切结束”几个字。玛丽·维塞拉的一生就这样彻底画上了句号。
There was one mention of her in an illustrated paper published in Graz, which said, quite erroneously, Mary Vetsara died in Venice and has been buried in Bohemia. But otherwise, to quote Frederick Morton, her name never appeared again in any book, magazine or newspaper published in Austria, Hungary. No printed mention was ever made of her death or even her life. It was as though nobody remembered that she had walked the earth. So that is a contrast with Diana in the 90s. Yeah.
格拉茨出版的一份画报曾提到过她一次，但写得完全错误，称玛丽·维塞拉死于威尼斯，并已葬在波希米亚。但除此之外，引用弗雷德里克·莫顿的话说，她的名字再也没有出现在奥地利或匈牙利出版的任何书籍、杂志或报纸上。关于她的死，甚至她的生平，没有任何印刷品提及。就好像没人记得她曾活在这个世上一样。这与90年代的戴安娜形成了鲜明对比。是的。
Because nobody was going to leave the details of that alone. And in fact, they came up with all kinds of linked conspiracies to explain it. But I'm wondering, what about the foreign press? Well, come on to that and just a second, but you're absolutely right. Of course the foreign press does print it. and a problem for the Austro-Hungarian monarchy is there's an extremely large country to their north that prints everything in German
因为没人会放过其中的细节。事实上，他们提出了各种各样的关联阴谋论来解释这件事。但我很好奇，外国媒体呢？嗯，我们马上就会谈到这一点，但你说得完全正确。当然，外国媒体确实报道了。奥匈帝国面临的一个问题是，他们北边有一个非常大的国家，那里用德语印刷一切。
so people can read it and it's very easy for people to travel between Germany and Austria-Hungary with German newspapers so they're fooling nobody I mean people, everybody knows about it they don't fool anybody meanwhile what about Crown Prince Rudolf
所以人们可以读到它，而且人们带着德国报纸在德国和奥匈帝国之间往来非常容易，所以他们谁也骗不了。我的意思是，每个人都知道这件事，他们骗不了任何人。那么，皇太子鲁道夫的情况如何呢？
well they held an autopsy the same day the 31st and the autopsy concluded that on studying Rudolf's brain It was clear he was suffering from abnormal mental conditions and was in a state of mental confusion. And the Catholic Church said, oh, well, in that case, you know, he's not really a suicide, or even a murderer. He was, poor fellow.
嗯，他们在同一天，也就是31日进行了尸检，尸检结论是，在研究了鲁道夫的大脑后，很明显他患有异常的精神疾病，处于精神错乱状态。天主教会说，哦，既然这样，你知道，他并不是真正的自杀，甚至不是谋杀者。他是个可怜的家伙。
What a terrible shame. He can be buried on the cappucc crypt in Vienna alongside his ancestors. And this apparently was quite common. Vienna, you know, coroners or whatever were well known for fudging reports on suicides to allow, people to be buried according to the rights of the church. I think, though, it's very unusual for a case that is this high profile. So the Papal Nuncio in Vienna, and he says it's probably the first time that a papal nuncio had ever been obliged to attend the funeral of a murderer and a suicide.
真是太遗憾了。他可以被安葬在维也纳的卡普齐纳墓穴中，与他的祖先们在一起。这显然很常见。你知道，维也纳的验尸官之类的人以篡改自杀报告而闻名，以便让人们能够按照教会的仪式下葬。不过，我认为对于这种备受瞩目的案件来说，这非常不寻常。所以教廷驻维也纳大使说，这可能是教廷大使第一次被迫参加一个谋杀者和自杀者的葬礼。
Yeah, that's right. So he's not happy about it at all. And the Papal Nuncio actually then went to the hunting lodge and asked load of questions, kept kind of looking into it. So he could team up with Bratfish. Exactly. Set up an agency if the papal nunseeing doesn't work out. Brilliant.
是的，没错。所以他一点也不高兴。教廷大使后来甚至去了狩猎小屋，问了一堆问题，一直在调查这件事。这样他就可以和布拉特菲什联手了。没错。如果教廷大使的工作干不下去，就开一家侦探社。太棒了。
So anyway, Rudolph lies in state for three days, various places in the Hofburg. And finally in the Hofburg Chapel, the Hofberg Capella. And there was a huge public crush. All thousands upon thousands of people, especially women, dressed in black.
总之，鲁道夫在霍夫堡的各个地方停灵了三天。最后是在霍夫堡礼拜堂。当时有大量民众涌入。成千上万的人，尤其是穿着黑衣的女性。
So many that people were injured or fainted in the crowd. Ambulances had to be called, and it ended thousands of people being turned away. And then the funeral took place on Tuesday, the 5th of February in the Capuchin Church and the Capuchin Cript, which you can visit. I mean, you can see Crown Prince Rudolf's tomb. I went to see it last last summer. Of course, this is not the last, you know, very high profile funeral there's going to be in Vienna. And not for the last time, Franz Joseph specifically asks foreign dignitaries not to come. And in a preview of what will happen in 1914, the worst person, the last person that you would ever want at a somber family occasion, the Kaiser says, no, no, I'm coming anyway.
人数多到人群中有人受伤或晕倒。不得不叫来救护车，最终导致成千上万的人被拒之门外。葬礼于2月5日星期二在卡普齐纳教堂和卡普齐纳墓穴举行，你可以去参观。我的意思是，你可以看到皇太子鲁道夫的墓。我去年夏天去看了。当然，这不会是维也纳最后一场备受瞩目的葬礼。而且弗朗茨·约瑟夫也不是最后一次专门要求外国政要不要出席。在预演1914年将要发生的事情时，那个最糟糕的人，那个你最不希望出现在庄严肃穆的家庭场合的人，德皇说，不，不，我还是要来。
And Franz Diof has to send him a special message. You may judge how deeply crushed my family is if we have to address this request, even to you. Even to you. Even to you. Even to you. If you'd suffered a terrible tragedy. And then Kaiser Wilhelm I announced that he was going to turn up. I mean, that would be the worst. So the funeral was another incredibly sort of Viennese occasion. The ritual would be that the Chamberlain would knock on the door with the cappaging crypt. And the voice would say, who is it?
弗朗茨·约瑟夫不得不给他发了一条特别信息。如果你不得不提出这个请求，你就能判断出我的家人有多么崩溃，即使是对你。即使是对你。即使是对你。即使是对你。如果你遭受了可怕的悲剧。然后德皇威廉一世宣布他要出现。我的意思是，那将是最糟糕的。所以葬礼又是另一个极其维也纳式的场合。仪式是侍从官敲响卡普齐纳墓穴的门。里面的声音会问，是谁？
And he'd say, his most serene imperial and royal highness, the Archduke Crown, Prince Rudolph of Habsburg. And the voice would say, we know him not. And they'd repeat this. And then eventually, when the voice said, who is there, the Chamberlain would say, your brother, Rudolf, a poor sinner. And then at last, they would open the door and let him in. And then right at the end, very memorable moment, when they carried the body down to the crypt, Franz Joseph the Emperor, that's the one moment in public.
他会说，他那最宁静的帝国和皇家殿下，哈布斯堡的皇太子鲁道夫。里面的声音会说，我们不认识他。他们会重复这个过程。最后，当声音问是谁在那里时，侍从官会说，你的兄弟，鲁道夫，一个可怜的罪人。然后他们终于打开门让他进去。最后，在非常令人难忘的时刻，当他们把遗体抬进墓穴时，皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫，那是他在公共场合唯一的一次。
One of the only moments in his entire life, probably the only moment, when he lost control of his public dignity. And he burst out crying and he broke down and he was kissing the casket. sobbing, the one moment when you see the man, you know, the grieving father behind the facade of the sort of the imperial walrus. Yeah. So if we widen the picture out a bit, at one level, it's only a royal scandal. But the great sort of Austrian music critic, the most forbidding critic in Vienna at the day
他一生中仅有的几次，可能也是唯一一次失去公共尊严的时刻。他放声大哭，崩溃了，亲吻着棺材。啜泣着，这是你看到那个人的时刻，你知道，在那种帝国海象胡须的伪装下，那个悲伤的父亲。是的。所以如果我们把视野放宽一点，在某种层面上，这只是一桩皇室丑闻。但是当时维也纳最令人敬畏的评论家，伟大的奥地利音乐评论家
was a guy called Edwa Hanslich. And he wrote afterwards, he said, I've lived through the saddest catastrophes in Vienna. I've lived through revolutions, the loss of land, murderous. devastations by flood and fire, but nothing of all this is comparable to the horror of January the 30th. The disconsolate, desperate turbulence which ripped through the entire population is indescribable. And we know from, I mean, you mentioned Diana a few times. Yeah. How these sort of personal tragedies can often cut through with the great mass of the population in a way that geopolitical things don't. Yeah. I mean, you said that Diana's world wasn't Gothic. It was Hello
是一个叫爱德华·汉斯利克的人。他后来写道，他说，我经历过维也纳最悲惨的灾难。我经历过革命、土地丧失、洪水和火灾带来的毁灭性打击，但这一切都无法与1月30日的恐怖相比。那种席卷了整个民众的绝望和动荡是无法形容的。我们知道，我的意思是，你提到了几次戴安娜。是的。这些个人悲剧往往能以地缘政治事件无法做到的方式触动广大民众。是的。我的意思是，你说戴安娜的世界不是哥特式的。那是《Hello》杂志之类的。
magazine and everything. Yeah. And so it seemed expressive of a kind of age of celebrity that was running out of control. But presumably in the Viennese context, there are all kinds of cultural swells that find echoes in this case. And also there is the sense that the crown prince has gone. The emperor doesn't have another direct male heir. And it must have symbolized for people at the time in the empire.
杂志等等。是的。所以它似乎表达了一种失控的名人时代。但大概在维也纳的背景下，有各种各样的文化浪潮在这个案件中找到了回响。而且还有一种感觉，皇太子走了。皇帝没有另一个直系男性继承人。这在当时一定象征着帝国的人们。
an anxiety that indeed the storm clouds are gathering, don't you think? Yes, I think exactly both those things. I think, first of all, it's a huge shop for the dynasty because, as you say, he doesn't have another son, so they're going to have to search elsewhere in the family tree for an heir. Of course, the man that they find, turns out to be a great friend of the rest of his history, but a slightly ill-fated figure in his own right, although the bird population of Central Europe might not agree. And I think you're dead right.
一种焦虑，风暴云确实正在聚集，你不觉得吗？是的，我想正是这两点。我认为，首先，这对王朝来说是一个巨大的打击，因为正如你所说，他没有另一个儿子，所以他们必须在家族树的其他地方寻找继承人。当然，他们找到的那个人，后来成了他余生的一位好朋友，但他自己也是一个命运多舛的人物，尽管中欧的鸟类可能不会同意。而且我认为你说得完全对。
the cultural atmosphere of fantasy like in Vienna, the sense of neurosis, the sense of introspection of cultural anxiety, also cultural excitement, of course, this seems reflective of that world. And also of the German-speaking world more generally, because Wagner is, I mean, you know, the Lieberstadt, the idea of love and death. Yeah. And two lovers who are united in death. Yeah, Tristan Rizolda. Yeah, exactly. I mean, it's probably the most celebrated work of music that has been produced in the late 19th century. And we've seen how much a part it is of the kind of cultural furniture of people at this age. It must just be overwhelming. Completely.
像维也纳那样的幻想文化氛围，那种神经质的感觉，那种内省的感觉，那种文化焦虑，当然还有文化兴奋，这似乎反映了那个世界。也反映了更广泛的德语世界，因为瓦格纳，我的意思是，你知道，爱与死。是的。两个在死亡中结合的恋人。是的，《特里斯坦与伊索尔德》。是的，没错。我的意思是，这可能是19世纪末创作的最著名的音乐作品。我们已经看到它在那个时代人们的文化家具中占有多大的比重。这一定让人难以承受。完全是。
And precisely because it's overwhelming, that's why you get the conspiracy theorists. So we talked about this with the Kennedy assassination, with lots of things. what appears to be a freak event, if it's seen by the public as cataclysmic and of seismic importance, people will often refuse to accept. They don't like chance, luck, you know, personal quirks in history. Great events must have great causes. And so people look for conspiracy theories that are related to the political anxieties of the day.
正是因为它让人难以承受，所以才会有阴谋论者。我们谈论肯尼迪遇刺案时也谈到过这一点，很多事情都是这样。如果一个看似怪异的事件被公众视为灾难性的、具有地震般的重要性，人们往往会拒绝接受。他们不喜欢历史中的偶然、运气、你知道，个人怪癖。伟大的事件必须有伟大的原因。所以人们寻找与当时政治焦虑相关的阴谋论。
So people say, I mean, first of all, there are the sort of more humdrum conspiracy theories, Mary murdered Rudolph or her relatives murdered Rudolph, perhaps because they found out he'd given her gonorrhea and they wanted to punish him for it. What about Stephanie? Yeah, there are theories that Grand Princess Stephanie did it because she were jealous, of course. The Freemasons, the Jesuits, the Jews, Bismarck did it. Not the Kaiser. The Kaiser, no, there are theories that the Kaiser did it. But the most common, and this obviously reflects the political atmosphere of the day,
所以人们说，我的意思是，首先，有一些比较平庸的阴谋论，玛丽谋杀了鲁道夫，或者她的亲戚谋杀了鲁道夫，也许是因为他们发现他把淋病传染给了她，他们想惩罚他。斯蒂芬妮呢？是的，有理论说皇太子妃斯蒂芬妮做了这件事，因为她嫉妒，当然。共济会、耶稣会、犹太人、俾斯麦干的。不是德皇。德皇，不，有理论说德皇干的。但最常见的是，这显然反映了当时的政治氛围，
that, I mean, this is such a weird theory. He either killed himself or was murdered because he was about to be exposed as having plotted to seize the throne of Hungary from his father and break away from his father and set up a secessionist Hungarian kingdom. Well, I guess that's expressive of what is clearly a deep sense of tension between father and son. But also between the two halves of the empire. Yeah.
我的意思是，这是一个非常奇怪的理论。他自杀或被谋杀，是因为他即将被揭露策划从他父亲手中夺取匈牙利王位，脱离他父亲，建立一个分裂的匈牙利王国。嗯，我想这表达了父子之间明显的深层紧张关系。但也反映了帝国两半之间的紧张关系。是的。
And he's, you know, the emperor is obsessing about this even on the day of his son's suicide. Right. Isn't there a theory that was proposed by Emperor Zeta, who was the last empress, that it was the French and that has been organized by Clemoso, which I think is generally not regarded as plausible. Why did Clemoso do it? Remind me why Clemenceau wanted to kill Crown Prince Rudolph? Well, he wasn't even, I think, he wasn't even in Parliament at this time. I think she made it up, but she lived to a kind of ripe old age. I think she kind of died in the 70s or something.
而且他，你知道，皇帝甚至在他儿子自杀的那天还在纠结这件事。对。不是有一个由最后一位皇后齐塔提出的理论吗，说是法国人干的，是由克列孟梭组织的，我认为这通常被认为不可信。为什么克列孟梭要这么做？提醒我为什么克列孟梭想杀皇太子鲁道夫？嗯，我想他当时甚至不在议会。我想是她编造的，但她活到了相当大的年纪。我想她是在70年代左右去世的。
She did, yeah. Maybe even the 80s. And she kept repeating this. I have to admit, I showed Herkulean self-control by not falling down lots of rabbit holes online. Because there's so much stuff online about this by people, because people love Cecee and they love Crown Prince Rudolph. So if you go to the Capuchin crypt, they have tombs of all the Habsburgs. And some of these are like massive figures. I don't know, Maria Teresa or something.
是的，确实。甚至可能是80年代。她一直在重复这个说法。我必须承认，我表现出了赫拉克勒斯般的自制力，没有在网上掉进各种兔子洞。因为网上关于这个话题的内容太多了，因为人们喜欢茜茜公主，喜欢皇太子鲁道夫。所以如果你去卡普齐纳墓穴，那里有所有哈布斯堡家族的墓。其中一些是像玛丽亚·特蕾莎那样的大人物。
But Crown Prince Rudolf's tomb has more flowers, has a lot of flowers, you know, given that he never wielded power. And actually, in the grand scheme of things, you could argue, it's not a terribly consequential person. But there's clearly something about his story that speaks to people, even today in the 21st century. It's kind of Kurt Cobain of Austria-Hungary. I mean, to talk about the political meaning of it, anyone, any historian writing out the Austro-Hungarian Empire or the Habsburgs, you know, gives this a lot of welly, understandably. and they see it as symptomatic of this wider loss of confidence of the Imperial project. It's the Titanic. Yeah.
但皇太子鲁道夫的墓上有更多的花，有很多花，你知道，考虑到他从未掌握过权力。实际上，从宏观角度来看，你可以说，他并不是一个非常有影响力的人。但他的故事中显然有一些东西，即使在21世纪，也能引起人们的共鸣。他就像奥匈帝国的库尔特·科本。我的意思是，谈到它的政治意义，任何撰写奥匈帝国或哈布斯堡王朝历史的历史学家，你知道，都会对此大书特书，这是可以理解的。他们将其视为帝国项目失去信心的症状。这就是泰坦尼克号。是的。
But as with the Titanic, I think a lot of this is massively overblown. So we know why Mary and Rudolph killed themselves. I mean, he's morbid. He's got gonorrhea. Today he would be diagnosed as having mental health issues of a very serious kind. That does speak of something that is genuine, which is the way in which to be born into the Habsburg dinner. is to feel trapped, is to feel a prisoner. We have all these counts of both men and women almost sewing themselves into their uniforms
但就像泰坦尼克号一样，我认为很多东西被严重夸大了。所以我们知道玛丽和鲁道夫为什么要自杀。我的意思是，他病态。他得了淋病。今天他会被诊断出患有非常严重的心理健康问题。这确实说明了一些真实的东西，那就是出生在哈布斯堡王朝意味着什么。是感到被困住，感到像个囚犯。我们有所有这些关于男人和女人几乎把自己缝进制服的记录
and their clothing. So, you know, Franz Ferdinand, when he gets shot, it takes time for them to realize that the blood is welling out. We're going to hear something similar about Cici in due course, I think. That there is, that monarchy is a kind of trap for those who find themselves enclosed within it. Very 21st century theme. Right? And people often say that's about the House of Windsor, don't they?
和他们的衣服里。所以，你知道，弗朗茨·斐迪南被枪杀时，他们花了一段时间才意识到血正在涌出来。我想我们以后会听到关于茜茜公主的类似事情。那就是，君主制对于那些发现自己被困在其中的人来说是一种陷阱。非常21世纪的主题。对吧？人们经常说那是关于温莎家族的，不是吗？
Yeah, but the difference with the House of Windsor is that they can kind of make radio programs about it and kind of have features in newspapers talking about bad mental health. Whereas Rudolph couldn't. And the idea of any of these people really having a kind of interior emotional life is verboten. Yeah. Interesting that nobody had done this before him, though, no? What does that tell you? Something changed in the second half of the 19th century that made this possible that would not. I mean, it's hard to imagine a 14th century prince. No, and it's changing nowhere more than in Vienna. Yeah, exactly.
是的，但温莎家族的不同之处在于，他们可以制作关于它的广播节目，可以在报纸上刊登讨论心理健康问题的专题。而鲁道夫却不能。而且这些人真正拥有某种内在情感生活的想法是被禁止的。是的。有趣的是，在他之前没有人这样做过，不是吗？这说明了什么？19世纪下半叶发生了一些变化，使得这成为可能，而以前不会。我的意思是，很难想象一个14世纪的王子会这样做。不，而且这种变化在维也纳最为明显。是的，没错。
Vienna is the, you know, this is where all these ideas of repression and neurosis and psychosis and everything are being defined at this very moment. Maybe a particular kind of introspection and a sense of yourself or I don't know. He's vibe-lauding, I believe it's the phrase. It's vibe-lauding. Is that the phrase? Gen C joins us on the podcast. Brilliant. So what happened next?
维也纳是，你知道，这就是所有关于压抑、神经症、精神病等概念在这一刻被定义的地方。也许是一种特殊的内省和自我意识，或者我不知道。我相信那是“Vibe-lauding”（德语：自我陶醉/自我沉溺）。是“Vibe-lauding”吗？那是这个词吗？Gen C加入了我们的播客。太棒了。那么接下来发生了什么？
Franch Joseph, I mean, this is very Freudian, and Frederick Morton makes this point in his book. He wants to erase every trace, every memory of this incident, and the way he does it is by literally erasing the place. So the Hunting Lodge at Myeling, every trace of it is expunged from the earth. It's completely pulled down,
弗朗茨·约瑟夫，我的意思是，这非常弗洛伊德，弗雷德里克·莫顿在他的书中也指出了这一点。他想抹去这次事件的每一个痕迹、每一段记忆，他这样做的方式是字面意义上抹去了那个地方。所以迈耶林的狩猎小屋，它的每一个痕迹都被从地球上抹去了。它被完全拆毁，
and it is replaced with a Carmelite convent, which stands to this day, and the nuns of the convent are enjoined to offer daily prayers for the salvation of the late crown prince. He needs all the prayers you can get. He does. So the most likely heir to Franz Joseph now is his younger brother, Karl Ludwig, who is in his late 50s. But Carl Ludwig's not in brilliant health. And in the late 1890s, in 1896, he went on a sort of pilgrimage to Palestine, then part of the Ottoman Empire.
取而代之的是一座加尔默罗会修道院，至今仍屹立在那里，修道院的修女们被要求每天为已故皇太子的灵魂得救祈祷。他需要他能得到的所有祈祷。他确实需要。所以弗朗茨·约瑟夫现在最可能的继承人是他那50多岁的弟弟卡尔·路德维希。但卡尔·路德维希的健康状况并不好。在19世纪90年代末，1896年，他去巴勒斯坦进行了一次朝圣，当时那里是奥斯曼帝国的一部分。
and he decided to drink some water from the River Jordan. He basically drank dirty water polluted with sewage. So do we get his dysentery returned to the show? Dissentiary returned to the show and carried off Karl Ludwig. And the heir became his son, Rudolf's protege, Franz Ferdinand. So a great friend of the rest of his history, but we know what became of him. And actually, this brings us to the wider issue of tragedy in the Habsburgs. So you've already alluded to this.
他决定喝约旦河的水。他基本上喝了被污水污染的脏水。所以我们又要让痢疾回到节目中了吗？痢疾回到了节目中，带走了卡尔·路德维希。继承人变成了他的儿子，鲁道夫的门生，弗朗茨·斐迪南。所以他是他余生的一位好朋友，但我们知道他后来怎么样了。实际上，这把我们带到了哈布斯堡王朝悲剧的更广泛问题上。所以你已经提到了这一点。
In the decade after Rudolf's death, his mother Cece cut an ever more, ever lonelier and more melancholy figure. So she basically, she's dressed always in black and mourning for her son. She drifts around the Mediterranean. She's thinner than ever. She looks very sad, you know, solitary. And in autumn of 1898, she was staying at Lake Geneva. and Franz Joseph, her husband was still writing to her all the time from Vienna,
在鲁道夫死后的十年里，他的母亲茜茜公主表现得越来越孤独和忧郁。所以她基本上总是穿着黑色的衣服，为她的儿子哀悼。她在地中海漂泊。她比以往任何时候都瘦。她看起来非常悲伤，你知道，孤独。1898年秋天，她住在日内瓦湖。而她的丈夫弗朗茨·约瑟夫仍然一直在维也纳给她写信，
and he would write these very sweet letters, the end of one letter, he signs off, he says sort of farewell, my most beautiful, my best and sweetest angel. But the sad thing is she never got to read this particular letter, because while it was en route, on the 10th of September 1898, she was boarding the steamer to Montreux on Lake Geneva, which just had one lady in waiting with her, and she was standing amid the crush of people when suddenly, she collapsed and no one could work out why she collapsed at first. As you said, she's very
他会写这些非常甜蜜的信，一封信的结尾，他签上名，他说，再见，我最美丽、最好、最甜美的天使。但可悲的是，她从来没有读到这封信，因为当它在途中时，1898年9月10日，她正在日内瓦湖登上前往蒙特勒的汽船，身边只有一个侍女，当她站在拥挤的人群中时，突然，她倒下了，起初没人能弄明白她为什么倒下。正如你所说，她被
tightly sewn into her corset. Yeah. And when finally they worked out what happened, they realized that she had been stabbed through the heart with a sharpened stiletto, a kind of improvised stiletto by an Italian anarchist called Luigi Lucani. And he had traveled to Geneva to kill a royal because it was a favorite royal hangout. And he said afterwards he didn't care, which one he killed as long as he killed one. And Cici was the person that he killed. And when the news got back to Vienna, Franz Joseph, apparently, when he heard the news,
紧紧地缝在紧身胸衣里。是的。当他们最终弄清楚发生了什么时，他们意识到她被一个名叫路易吉·卢切尼的意大利无政府主义者用一把磨尖的细剑，一种简易的细剑刺穿了心脏。他去日内瓦是为了杀一个皇室成员，因为那是皇室成员最喜欢去的地方。他后来声称他不在乎杀的是哪一个，只要杀了一个就行。茜茜公主就是他杀的那个人。当消息传回维也纳时，弗朗茨·约瑟夫，显然，当他听到这个消息时，
he sobbed uncontrollably. And then he said to one of his aides, So I am to be spared nothing in this world. Nobody knows the love we had for each other. Which is a sort of bitterly ironic thing for him to say. Yeah. So this for him was the crowning blow. He still had his actress, Katarina Schrapp, though their relationship had actually cooled by this point.
他无法控制地啜泣。然后他对他的一个助手说，在这个世界上，我什么都不能幸免。没人知道我们彼此之间的爱。对他来说，这是一种带有苦涩讽刺意味的话。是的。所以对他来说，这是致命的一击。他虽然还有他的女演员卡塔琳娜·施拉特，尽管他们的关系此时已经变冷了。
He's very lonely. He writes to Katerina Shratt at one point. I feel endlessly sad in my hopeless loneliness. His son has killed himself. His wife has been murdered. He's effectively on his own. He lives for another 18 years after his wife's death. It seems incredibly old at this point.
他非常孤独。他在某个时候写信给卡塔琳娜·施拉特。我在绝望的孤独中感到无尽的悲伤。他的儿子自杀了。他的妻子被谋杀了。他实际上是孤身一人。他在妻子死后又活了18年。此时他看起来老得不可思议。
He actually looks older than he is. So he turned 70 in 1900, but at this point he looked about 150. And people talked about him as a relic at this point. They would call him the last night or the old gentleman or something. And he remains enormously popular, Franz Joseph, a great rallying point for his empire. And his suffering actually worked quite well as a political asset because the papers would call him the man of sorrows. Sort of a man who has lost everything, wife, son, you know, all the light has gone from his life. And yet still he dedicates himself every day, gets up at four o'clock in the morning, his red boxes to his, yeah, to the people.
他实际上看起来比实际年龄要老。所以他在1900年满70岁，但此时他看起来大约150岁。人们在此时谈论他就像谈论一个遗迹。他们会称他为最后的骑士或老绅士之类的。他仍然非常受欢迎，弗朗茨·约瑟夫，是他帝国的伟大凝聚点。他的痛苦实际上作为一种政治资产运作得相当好，因为报纸会称他为“忧患之子”。一个失去了一切的人，妻子、儿子，你知道，他生命中所有的光芒都消失了。然而他仍然每天致力于工作，早上四点起床，他的红盒子，是的，为了他帝国的人民。
of his empire. But I suppose another way of looking at it is precisely because he is such a relic. He seems like the embodiment of an antiquated institutional conservatism, an empire that seems utterly beleaguered by the modern world, and an empire that feels itself to be so embattled. And of course, that's the context in which his heir, who he doesn't get on with at all now, Franz Ferdinand, goes off to Bosnia to see some army maneuvers in 1914. And Tom, we all know how that story was to end. We do. Well, thank you, Dominic. A Gothic chiller. An amazing story. And we have a bonus out this week on the nephew of one of the characters in this series, and that is Baron Nopshire, Cici's Chamberlain. And his nephew is also Franz Baron Nopshire. And he is one of the most remarkable figures in the entire history of paleontology. I see Dominic's face light up. at the mention of that word.
但我认为另一种看待它的方式是，正是因为他是一个遗迹，他看起来像是过时的制度保守主义的化身，一个似乎被现代世界完全围困的帝国，一个感到自己四面楚歌的帝国。当然，这就是他的继承人，他现在根本合不来的弗朗茨·斐迪南，在1914年去波斯尼亚观看一些军事演习的背景。汤姆，我们都知道那个故事将如何结束。我们知道。好吧，谢谢你，多米尼克。一部哥特式惊悚片。一个惊人的故事。本周我们有一个关于本系列角色之一的侄子的额外节目，那就是巴伦·诺普舍，茜茜公主的侍从官。他的侄子也是弗朗茨·巴伦·诺普舍。他是古生物学史上最杰出的人物之一。我看到多米尼克提到那个词时脸都亮了。
So Nobscher, Knopshaw, Jr., absolutely titanic figure in the history of the study of dinosaurs, but he also, he hung out with bandits
所以诺普舍，小诺普舍，恐龙研究史上绝对泰坦级的人物，但他还和强盗混在一起
in Albania, became a spy in the First World War, is in the Guinness Book of Records as the first man to have hijacked a plane, and his end has some striking. And actually, I wonder if they're entirely
在阿尔巴尼亚，在第一次世界大战中成为间谍，作为第一个劫机的人被载入吉尼斯世界纪录，他的结局有一些惊人的。实际上，我怀疑它们是否完全是
coincidental, echoes of the miling incident. So if you're already a member of The Restis History Club, you already have had that. If you're not, then you can sign up at the rest is history.com. That sounds amazing. And the good news doesn't stop there. Because Dominic, we're also doing a live show, aren't we, about the ultimate Victorian adventure, which is the Abyssinian expedition of 1868, all kicked off when the Abyssinian
巧合，迈耶林事件的回响。所以如果你已经是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你已经听过了。如果你不是，那么你可以在therestis history.com注册。听起来太棒了。好消息还不止于此。因为多米尼克，我们也要做一个现场节目，不是吗，关于终极的维多利亚时代冒险，也就是1868年的阿比西尼亚远征，这一切都始于阿比西尼亚
emperor wrote a letter to Queen Victoria, and she neglected to reply. in a massive strop and chaos ensued. And actually, I think that ends with him, with the Abyssinian Emperor killing himself. So a bit of a theme developing there. Yeah, it's absolutely amazing story. It's one of the most lurid, implausible and entertaining of all 19th century imperial adventures. So I'm really looking forward to the show. It's very flashman, isn't it?
皇帝写了一封信给维多利亚女王，而她忽略了回复。他大发雷霆，随之而来的是混乱。实际上，我认为那以他，以阿比西尼亚皇帝自杀而告终。所以那里正在形成一个主题。是的，这是一个绝对惊人的故事。它是19世纪所有帝国冒险中最耸人听闻、最不可思议且最有趣的故事之一。所以我真的很期待这个节目。这非常像《弗莱什曼》，不是吗？
There's a flashman book about it, Flashman on the March. Yeah, it's the ideal Flashman story, if you like Flashman. And even if you don't, it's still brilliant. Anyway, that is at the South Bank in London on Friday the 4th of September. And you can get tickets once again at the rest is history.com. I think you should just bookmark the resthistory.com and buy everything it's got to offer. And Dominic, I have even more exciting news because we are running a summer sale. And so for a limited time, if you want to sign up to the Rest of History Club,
有一本关于它的《弗莱什曼》书，《弗莱什曼在行军》。是的，如果你喜欢《弗莱什曼》，这是理想的《弗莱什曼》故事。即使你不喜欢，它仍然很精彩。总之，那是在9月4日星期五在伦敦南岸。你可以再次在therestis history.com买票。我认为你应该把therestis history.com加入书签，并购买它所提供的一切。多米尼克，我有更令人兴奋的消息，因为我们正在进行夏季促销。所以，在有限的时间内，如果你想注册“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，
listen about the dinosaurs and a host of other supplementary benefits, then you will get an extra 20% off an annual membership. using the code summer 26. And this is only valid until the 31st of August. So hurry, hurry, hurry, while stocks last. So that is the myling incident. Next week we begin a six-part series on another royal. But this is a royal who lives to a ripe old age and does heroic things, all her reign.
听听关于恐龙和一系列其他补充福利的内容，那么你将获得年度会员资格额外20%的折扣。使用代码summer 26。这仅在8月31日前有效。所以快点，快点，快点，售完即止。这就是迈耶林事件。下周我们将开始一个关于另一位皇室成员的六部分系列。但这是一位活到高龄并在她统治期间做出英雄事迹的皇室成员。
And it is Elizabeth I. and we will be looking at the road that takes Elizabeth First to the fateful decision to execute Mary Queen of Scots and thereby inspire the launching of the Spanish Armada against her. Francis Drake's in it, isn't he? Francis Drake is in it. Sir Philip Sidney. Sir Philip Sidney's in it. Edward Campion, the Jesuit is in it. Lord Cecil is in it.
那就是伊丽莎白一世。我们将看看伊丽莎白一世做出处决苏格兰玛丽女王这一重大决定，从而激发西班牙无敌舰队对她发动进攻的道路。弗朗西斯·德雷克在里面，不是吗？弗朗西斯·德雷克在里面。菲利普·西德尼爵士在里面。菲利普·西德尼爵士在里面。爱德华·坎皮恩，那个耶稣会士在里面。塞西尔勋爵在里面。
It's just non-stop Elizabethan action. Brilliant. So if you love a Tudor, you're going to love this series. We will see you then. Bye-bye. Alfie to say. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这简直是伊丽莎白时代的动作大片。太棒了。所以如果你喜欢都铎王朝，你会喜欢这个系列的。我们到时见。再见。阿尔菲说。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。